This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. In July 1798, an English poet visited the countryside on the banks of the river Y. On seeing the natural beauty of the area, William Wordsworth composed a poem. It's titled, Lines Written a few miles above Tintan Abbey. At one point, he describes the effect of the landscape on his psychological state. He writes, and I have felt a presence that disturbs me with the joy of elevated thoughts, a sense sublime of something far more deeply interfused,
这里是Hidden Brain。我是Shankar Vedantam。1798年7月，一位英国诗人造访了Y河畔的乡村。在目睹了当地的自然美景后，威廉·华兹华斯创作了一首诗。诗的标题是《丁登寺几英里外所作诗行》。在诗中，他描述了景观对他的心理状态产生的影响。他写道：“我感受到一种存在，它以崇高思想的喜悦震撼着我，一种深邃的崇高感，仿佛某种事物深深地交融其中，”
whose dwelling is the light of setting suns and the round ocean and the living air, and the blue sky and in the mind of man, a motion and a spirit that impels all thinking things, all objects of all thought, and rolls through all things. Now, the romantic poets were sometimes given to literary excess. They felt things deeply, and they wrote effusively. But more than two centuries after Wordsworth composed his poem, some scientists today are asking an unusual question.
“它栖居于落日的余晖、浩瀚的海洋、鲜活的空气、蔚蓝的天空，以及人类的心智之中；它是一种运动，一种精神，推动着所有思考的事物、所有思想的对象，并贯穿于万物之中。”浪漫主义诗人有时会沉溺于文学上的过度表达。他们感受深刻，笔触奔放。但在华兹华斯创作这首诗两个多世纪后，今天的一些科学家正在提出一个不同寻常的问题。
Were the romantics onto something? This week on Hidden Brain, we look at what happens when we stop, really stop to smell the roses For centuries, one of the central challenges For centuries, one of the central challenges in human behavior has been the problem of suffering. We all have aches and ailments. setbacks at work, and conflicts in personal relationships.
浪漫主义者是否发现了什么？本周的Hidden Brain，我们将探讨当我们停下来，真正停下来去“闻闻玫瑰花香”时会发生什么。几个世纪以来，人类行为的核心挑战之一一直是苦难的问题。我们都有病痛和苦恼，工作上的挫折，以及人际关系中的冲突。
Many years ago, the psychologist Dachar Keltner found himself in a world of suffering. He was in his early 30s and had just moved from California to Wisconsin. What happened to me, Shankar, is I lived a life largely in California, in the hills, in the mountains, in the oceans, in the culture, and so forth. And I went 2,000 miles away, and it was flat. and there were storms and there was snow and people rooted for the Packers and they ate Bratworths
多年前，心理学家Dacher Keltner发现自己陷入了苦难的世界。那时他刚过30岁，刚从加利福尼亚搬到威斯康星州。“Shankar，发生在我身上的是，我大部分时间生活在加州，在山丘、山脉、海洋和文化中等等。然后我去了2000英里外的地方，那里地势平坦，有风暴，有积雪，人们支持包装工队，吃着德国小香肠，”
and, you know, there was no Mexican food and the weather and the cold. The cold rattled me. I felt like Camus' stranger in a way. Like I am in a strange land that I just physically, temperature-wise, climate-wise, people-wise, I felt like a fish out of water,
“你知道，那里没有墨西哥食物，还有天气和寒冷。寒冷让我感到不安。在某种程度上，我感觉自己就像加缪笔下的‘局外人’。我身处一个陌生的地方，无论是从生理上、温度上、气候上，还是人际关系上，我都感觉自己像一条离水的鱼，”
even though I look like somebody from Wisconsin and I'm, you know, of Northern European heritage. Daccar, who was just starting his career as a professor, started to experience extreme bouts of anxiety. I come from a family on my mom's side that has a lot of anxiety, and I started to have profound panic attacks, really beginning with the day that I departed to drive across the country to Wisconsin.
“尽管我看起来像个威斯康星人，而且我有着北欧血统。”Dacher当时刚开始担任教授，开始经历极度的焦虑。“我母亲那边的家族有很多人患有焦虑症，我开始出现严重的恐慌发作，真的就是从我开车横跨全国去威斯康星的那天开始的。”
I had probably, I would say, 70 or 80 a year, really technical or full-blown panic attacks when I was teaching, when I would go see a movie to try to relax, when I would fly on an airplane to go to a conference, when I would hear from a colleague. And it really caught me off guard, Shankar, like, wow, why am I feeling so estranged and anxious all the time? Everything around Dachar seemed to remind him of his isolation. Everywhere he went, he experienced vulnerability. He felt that his life was about to end.
“我一年大概会有70到80次，真正技术性或全面的恐慌发作，在我教书时，在我去看电影试图放松时，在我坐飞机去参加会议时，在我听到同事的消息时。Shankar，这真的让我措手不及，就像，哇，为什么我一直感到如此疏离和焦虑？”Dacher周围的一切似乎都在提醒他的孤立感。无论他走到哪里，他都感到脆弱。他觉得自己的生命即将终结。
My God, you know, for those people out in the audience who've had real panic attacks, they are spectacular and they hit you and you literally, the brain says you're dying. and your body is telling you, you, Dacker, Keltner, are dying, and you're about to die right here. It felt really solitary. And I remember there was this book about weird stories from Wisconsin about how anxious people ended up dying in Wisconsin because they would go out and start tilling the earth on their farm at 2 in the morning,
“天哪，你知道，对于那些在观众席中经历过真正恐慌发作的人来说，它们是非常壮观的，它们会击中你，你的大脑会字面上告诉你‘你要死了’。你的身体在告诉你，‘Dacher Keltner，你要死了，你马上就要死在这里了’。那种感觉真的很孤独。我记得有一本关于威斯康星怪谈的书，讲的是焦虑的人是如何在威斯康星死去的，因为他们会在凌晨2点出去在农场耕地，”
you know, and everything was frozen, and the guy froze to death. And I was like, this is going to happen to me. And it was happening to me. Dachar had moved across the country to join the University of Wisconsin, but his work provided no solace. I was getting rejected for grants. Papers were getting rejected. There was a conference on the social nature of emotion,
“你知道，一切都冻住了，那个人被冻死了。我当时想，这也会发生在我身上。而且它确实正在发生。”Dacher搬到全国各地加入威斯康星大学，但他的工作并没有提供慰藉。我的研究经费申请被拒绝了。论文被拒稿了。有一个关于情绪社会本质的会议，
which is what I was writing about and defined my career on. I got rejected from. I started a dream about people broadcasting all the rejections of my papers and ideas and the like. You know, I got a very mediocre to bad mid-career. review, it was a real struggle, to be quite honest, and a lot of suffering. So like many of us who've been through something similar, you tried to do a number of things to make yourself feel better. At one point, you and some fellow academics banded
“那是我正在撰写并定义我职业生涯的主题。我被拒绝了。我开始梦见人们广播我所有被拒的论文和想法之类的东西。你知道，我得到了一个非常平庸甚至糟糕的中期评估，说实话，那真是一场挣扎，充满了苦难。”所以，像许多经历过类似事情的人一样，你尝试做一些事情来让自己感觉好一点。有一次，你和一些学术同僚联合起来
together to form a basketball team. Tell me about that. Why did you do that and how did it go? We formed this team that we named the laughing amygdala. Because the amygdala was all the rage at the time. It was Joe Lidu, the amygdala, the threat center, et cetera. And what was great about our team, Shanker, is we were all professors and three graduate students. And we had this really unlikely team, and we won championships on the campus. We beat the football team, you know, the fraternities. And people were just stunned, you know.
组建了一支篮球队。告诉我关于那件事。你为什么那样做，结果如何？我们组建了这支球队，取名为“大笑的杏仁核”。因为当时杏仁核非常流行。那是Joe LeDoux的杏仁核，威胁中心等等。Shankar，我们球队最棒的地方在于，我们都是教授和三名研究生。我们组成了一支非常不可思议的球队，我们在校园里赢得了冠军。我们击败了橄榄球队，你知道，还有兄弟会。人们都惊呆了，你知道。
And so it was this magical run. And, you know, Shanker, from the solid. life of 3 a.m., I would go to the gym and play, and basketball is five people flowing in motion in a sense of, you know, just we're all connected doing things together. And when I'd walk to the gym, it felt like a sanctuary, that I would go there and leave behind the anxiety. I want to play a clip of music here, Doctor. It's from Raw Power, the 1973 album, by Iggy Pop and the Stooges.
所以那是一段神奇的旅程。而且，你知道，Shankar，从凌晨3点的孤独生活中，我会去健身房打球，篮球是五个人在运动中流动，有一种，你知道，我们都在一起做事的连接感。当我走到健身房时，它感觉像是一个避难所，我会去那里，把焦虑抛在脑后。我想在这里放一段音乐，Dacher。它来自Iggy Pop和The Stooges 1973年的专辑《Raw Power》。
Dachar, what memories does this music hold for you? Shankar, one of the, I think one of the deepest mysteries in science right now in the social sciences is why does music speak to us? And why does it speak to our soul? And when I was in Madison, Wisconsin, I was really, you know, fighting and with anxiety and, you know, trying to find my way in life. And at that time, I'd probably seen Iggy Pop kind of a godfather of punk rock about six to eight times. And he played, I think it was in Milwaukee, and I took some friends to the show. And it was just like basketball. like I was leaving behind the heat of anxiety of my academic life, my young career.
Dacher，这段音乐对你有什么回忆？Shankar，我认为目前社会科学中最深奥的谜团之一是，为什么音乐能与我们对话？为什么它能触动我们的灵魂？当我在威斯康星州麦迪逊市时，我真的，你知道，在与焦虑抗争，在生活中寻找方向。那时，我可能看过六到八次Iggy Pop的演出，他是朋克摇滚的教父。我想他是在密尔沃基演出的，我带了一些朋友去看。那就像打篮球一样，我把学术生活和年轻职业生涯中焦虑的热度抛在了脑后。
And I go to the show and I get up close and we're in this throbbing mosh pit that scientists now study. And he comes out and he sings all his great songs, you know, raw power and, you know, Lest for Life and Passenger. I know them, I'm singing. You know, at one point, he dives out into the crowd, and I'm right there, and I hold him, you know. And he's aloft on all of our hands. And Shankar, I touch his skin, and his skin feels like God. You know, I'm just like, I can't believe I'm holding Iggy Pop's bicep. So when I leave an Iggy Pop show, I'm drenched in sweat.
我去看了演出，我靠得很近，我们身处科学家现在研究的那种剧烈的“冲撞坑”（mosh pit）中。他走出来，唱着他所有伟大的歌曲，你知道，《Raw Power》，《Lust for Life》和《Passenger》。我熟悉它们，我在跟着唱。你知道，有一次，他跳入人群，我就在那里，我扶住了他。他被我们所有人的手托举着。Shankar，我触碰了他的皮肤，他的皮肤感觉就像上帝。你知道，我当时想，我简直不敢相信我正握着Iggy Pop的二头肌。所以当我离开Iggy Pop的演出时，我浑身湿透。
I don't know who I am. I'm embracing strangers. and I feel alive and pure. So I go back to Wisconsin, and I look at his CD, and it says, If you feel like writing me, drop me a line. Here's my address. So I write him. You know, and I tell him about all my stories, you know, seeing him
我不知道我是谁。我在拥抱陌生人，我感到活着且纯粹。所以我回到威斯康星，看着他的CD，上面写着：“如果你想写信给我，给我留个条。这是我的地址。”所以我写信给他。你知道，我告诉他我所有的故事，你知道，看他的演出，
and how important he's been to me as a young professor handling my struggles. Six months later, I get a letter back in this little shaky scrawl. And he says, thanks for all of your stories. I really appreciate them. Good luck getting access to the young skulls at UW. I dig teachers, Iggy Pop. And I like, I'm getting goosebumps talking about this now.
以及作为一名年轻教授在应对挣扎时，他对我有多重要。六个月后，我收到了一封回信，字迹有些颤抖。他说：“谢谢你所有的故事。我真的很感激。祝你在威斯康星大学获得年轻学子的认可好运。我喜欢老师，Iggy Pop。”我现在谈论这个时还会起鸡皮疙瘩。
Like, I held the letter and I'm like, my life's okay. I have courage and strength. And when I'd bounce up on the stage and teach my 300 students, getting my mediocre reviews and making mistakes here and there, I felt more strong and a lot.
就像，我拿着那封信，我想，我的生活没问题。我有勇气和力量。当我跳上讲台教我的300名学生时，尽管得到平庸的评价，偶尔犯错，但我感到更加强大和活着。
You were touched by the hand of God here, Daccar. The god father of punk rock. Another time, Dakar, you and your wife were outside watching a summer storm approach. warnings were going off. Describe for me what was happening and tell me what you both did next. My wife, Molly, grew up in San Francisco. We both were adapting to the weather and the climate and the landscape. And this storm starts rolling in and you could see it from afar and those clouds looked horrifying and they looked strong and dangerous. And then there was some kind of warning that said get into your basement, a tornado warning. And I think tornadoes did land that day. And for whatever
Dacher，你在这里被上帝之手触碰了。朋克摇滚的教父。还有一次，Dacher，你和你的妻子在外面看着一场夏季风暴逼近。警报声四起。请为我描述当时发生了什么，并告诉我你们接下来做了什么。我的妻子Molly在旧金山长大。我们都在适应那里的天气、气候和景观。这场风暴开始卷入，你可以从远处看到它，那些云看起来很可怕，看起来很强大且危险。然后有某种警报说进入地下室，是龙卷风警报。我想那天确实有龙卷风着陆。不管出于什么
reason, we said, let's feel it. Let's get out in the storm. Let's see what the mystery is. And let's just, you know, we couldn't really explain it, but we sat out on our swing, on our front porch as this wild storm ripped through, you know, Madison for half an hour, whatever it was, and rain and lightning and massive winds. And again, it felt, I just felt so alive and free of the shackles of my anxiety at the time. So it was a striking experience. So these all seem like very different experiences,
原因，我们说，让我们感受一下。让我们走进风暴。让我们看看那是什么奥秘。我们真的无法解释，但当这场狂野的风暴在麦迪逊肆虐了半小时左右时，我们坐在前廊的秋千上，你知道，雨水、闪电和巨大的风。再一次，我感觉自己如此活着，摆脱了当时焦虑的枷锁。所以那是一次令人震撼的经历。所以这些看起来是非常不同的经历，
enjoying teamwork in a basketball game, being part of a crowd at a music concert, watching a storm approach. Is there a common thread that connects these experiences, Dacker? You know, it was really interesting, Shankar, because I was really struggling in these four years, and I, you know, I was chronically anxious, tons of panic attacks, struggling career-wise, really feeling away from home. And I didn't know how to find happiness, which has been a life's puzzle for me in many ways. and I think what I was doing in these experiences is I was getting outside of myself
享受篮球比赛中的团队合作，成为音乐会人群的一部分，观看风暴逼近。Dacher，有什么共同点连接着这些经历吗？你知道，这真的很有趣，Shankar，因为我在那四年里真的很挣扎，我慢性焦虑，大量的恐慌发作，职业生涯挣扎，真的感觉远离家乡。我不知道如何找到幸福，这在很多方面一直是我人生的难题。我认为我在这些经历中所做的是，我走出了自我。
on the basketball court it's just the motion and the physicality and you're playing with five people I was losing myself and I lost myself right up front like in a mosh pit near seeing Iggy Pop and feeling the music
在篮球场上，那只是运动和身体素质，你和五个人一起打球，我迷失了自我，我在Iggy Pop的演出前排的冲撞坑里迷失了自我，感受着音乐，
and I lost myself in the storm and I was just like I was throwing myself into things where I could lose myself Like William Woodsworth two centuries ago, Daccar had begun to discover ways out of his narrow preoccupations. When we come back, the connections between these different experiences and the science behind a mind-expanding emotion.
我在风暴中迷失了自我，我只是把自己投入到那些能让我迷失自我的事情中。就像两个世纪前的威廉·华兹华斯一样，Dacher开始发现摆脱狭隘忧虑的方法。当我们回来时，我们将探讨这些不同经历之间的联系，以及一种能扩展思维的情绪背后的科学。
You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. University of California Berkeley psychologist Dachar Keltner studies what he calls pro-social emotions, feelings like love, compassion, and gratitude. Earlier in his life, he tried to get himself through a difficult time by immersing himself in sports, in music, and in the beauties of the natural world.
你正在收听Hidden Brain。我是Shankar Vedantam。这里是Hidden Brain。我是Shankar Vedantam。加州大学伯克利分校的心理学家Dacher Keltner研究他所谓的“亲社会情绪”，如爱、同情和感激。在他生命的早期，他试图通过沉浸在体育、音乐和自然世界的美景中来度过一段困难时期。
In time, he realized there was a common connection between these activities. They all activated a feeling, of being awe-struck. Now at the University of California, Berkeley, Dacre has spent years studying the science of awe. Dachar, I want to talk about your scientific explorations of awe, but so much of your intellectual journey
随着时间的推移，他意识到这些活动之间存在共同的联系。它们都激活了一种“敬畏”的感觉。现在在加州大学伯克利分校，Dacher花了多年时间研究敬畏的科学。Dacher，我想谈谈你对敬畏的科学探索，但你的许多智力旅程
starts with your personal journey. Both your parents were attuned to the world of art. Can you tell me about them? Yeah, you know, it's funny. I really lived a life that really is in some sense from my first moment. of being born in Mexico, a life as an experiment in awe, formative years in Laurel Canyon, California, in the late 60s, so much music going on, Joni Mitchell the Doors.
始于你的个人旅程。你的父母都与艺术世界息息相关。你能告诉我关于他们的事吗？是的，你知道，这很有趣。我确实过着一种在某种意义上从我出生在墨西哥的第一刻起，就像是一场敬畏实验的生活，60年代末在加州劳雷尔峡谷的成长岁月，那里有太多的音乐，Joni Mitchell，The Doors。
My dad was a painter, and he loved awe-inspiring, horrifying work, Goya, Velasquez, Francis Bacon, and others, right? Just as a kid, I was just seeing images all the time. And then my mom loved awe in literature, and it was getting her Ph.D., eventually taught at Cal State, Sacramento, and loved, you know, Virginia Woolf and her awesome portrayals of the mind, and the romanticism, and Wordsworth and Blake, and I would hear quotes of Blake, and she told me about the prelude of Wordsworth and, you know, and then also D.H. Lawrence and others, and so my parents were pointing me at an early age from, like, five and six, like, here are quotes about awe, here are paintings of awe. Here is music, you know, I remember listening to Sergeant Peppers when it came out, the Beatles, together as a family.
我父亲是一位画家，他热爱令人敬畏、恐怖的作品，戈雅、委拉斯开兹、弗朗西斯·培根等等，对吧？作为一个孩子，我一直在看这些图像。然后我母亲热爱文学中的敬畏，她正在攻读博士学位，后来在加州州立大学萨克拉门托分校任教，热爱弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫及其对心灵的敬畏描写，以及浪漫主义，华兹华斯和布莱克，我会听到布莱克的引语，她告诉我华兹华斯的《序曲》，还有D.H.劳伦斯等人，所以我的父母从我五六岁起就引导我，比如，这里有关于敬畏的引语，这里有敬畏的画作。这里有音乐，你知道，我记得我们全家一起听披头士乐队刚发行的《Sgt. Pepper's》。
Like, life's about awe. Go do it. Woke up, fell out of bed, dragged a comb across my head. Found the way downstairs and drank a cup. I understand that your family moved to a rural community in the foothills of the Sierras. And you and your brother, Rolf, spent many days roaming. outside in nature? You know, it was incredible.
就像，生活就是关于敬畏。去体验它吧。“醒来，滚下床，用梳子梳头。找到下楼的路，喝了一杯。”我了解到你的家人搬到了内华达山脉山脚下的一个农村社区。你和你的兄弟Rolf花了很多天在户外漫游，亲近自然？你知道，那真是太不可思议了。
My parents, you know, it was 1970. My mom had just gotten this job at Cal State, Sacramento, was an English professor teaching romanticism and the like. And they did what a lot of people did in that era. They moved to the country where it was cheaper. And we got an old beat-up Victorian five acres, and there were streams and creeks and ponds and railroad tracks we could follow. And we just wandered after school.
我的父母，你知道，那是1970年。我母亲刚在加州州立大学萨克拉门托分校得到这份工作，是一名教授浪漫主义文学的英语教授。他们做了那个时代很多人做的事。他们搬到了更便宜的乡村。我们得到了一栋破旧的维多利亚式房子，有五英亩地，那里有溪流、小河、池塘和我们可以跟随的铁轨。放学后我们就四处游荡。
didn't do any homework. And then as we got older, what we started to do, Shankar, is go to the rivers, you know, rafting, and then in particular to the Yuba River, which is this wild river and jump into it. And so I had this incredible childhood of biking and walking out in the country. We lived on a dirt road where when I'd go walk home from the school dance, it was pitch black, and I'd see this giant sky of stars, shooting stars. We slept outside. You know, so it was about wild awe. So that brings me to a question that I've been pondering for a bit in this conversation, which is that awe in general seems like an ineffable emotion.
不做任何家庭作业。然后随着我们长大，Shankar，我们开始做的是去河流，你知道，漂流，特别是去尤巴河，那是一条狂野的河流，跳进去。所以我有一个不可思议的童年，在乡村骑自行车和散步。我们住在一条土路上，当我从学校舞会走回家时，外面漆黑一片，我会看到巨大的星空，流星。我们在户外睡觉。你知道，所以那是关于野性的敬畏。这让我想到了我在这次谈话中一直在思考的一个问题，那就是敬畏通常看起来是一种难以言表的情绪。
It feels like it's very hard to wrap your arms around what exactly it is. And if you're going to study it scientifically, you have to know what it is that you're studying. Yeah. So about 20 years ago, I understand that you and a collaborator came up with a working definition of awe. Can you tell me how that came about? awe presents paradoxes right it's it seems ineffable and beyond words but yet people really want to talk about it it's mysterious and numinous and we probably can measure it and that's one of the tasks of science so jonathan height who is an early collaborator in my career and brilliant mind we got invited
感觉很难把握它到底是什么。如果你要科学地研究它，你必须知道你研究的是什么。是的。所以大约20年前，我了解到你和一位合作者提出了一个敬畏的工作定义。你能告诉我它是怎么来的吗？敬畏呈现出悖论，对吧？它似乎难以言表，超出了语言，但人们确实非常想谈论它。它是神秘而神圣的，我们可能可以测量它，这是科学的任务之一。所以Jonathan Haidt，我职业生涯早期的合作者，一位才华横溢的思想家，我们受邀
to write a paper for a special issue on pleasure and john and i had been talking about awe And we said awe, real, the key elements are when we encounter vast mysteries that we can't understand with our current knowledge. Or what we said was awe requires what we call the need for accommodation. You have to rearrange your knowledge structures just to make sense of what you've encountered. But I think for our conversation today, it's really awe is encountering vast mysteries. that we don't understand. So nature is very often a common source of awe for many people. I want to play for you an audio clip.
为一期关于快乐的特刊写一篇论文，John和我一直在谈论敬畏。我们说敬畏，真正的关键要素是我们遇到无法用现有知识理解的巨大奥秘时。或者我们说的是，敬畏需要我们所说的“顺应需求”。你必须重新安排你的知识结构，才能理解你所遇到的事物。但我认为对于我们今天的谈话，敬畏确实是遇到我们无法理解的巨大奥秘。所以自然界通常是许多人敬畏的共同来源。我想为你播放一段音频片段。
This is from a video made by a man named Paul Vasquez. His nickname is Bear. He saw something outside his home in Yosemite. Whoa! Oh my God! Oh my God! Oh, my God! Oh my God! Woo! Oh, wow!
这是由一个叫Paul Vasquez的人制作的视频，他的绰号是Bear。他在优胜美地家外看到了什么。“哇！天哪！天哪！天哪！天哪！呜！哇！”
Oh my God, it's full on! Double rainbow all the way across the sky! Oh my God! So, Dacker, you've seen this video, I believe. Yes. As a scientist, would you care to hazard a guess at what's happening inside Paul Vasquez's mind at that moment? This video is really what mystical experiences are like for people.
“天哪，太震撼了！双彩虹横跨整个天空！天哪！”所以，Dacher，我相信你看过这个视频。是的。作为一名科学家，你愿意冒险猜测Paul Vasquez那一刻内心在发生什么吗？这个视频确实是人们神秘体验的样子。
They laugh. They use language that is expansive and beyond the usual kinds of terms we use. It's full on. It's, oh, my God. We cry. We are moved outside of ourselves. You know, I want to play you a clip from the end of the same video, Dachar, because it brings up something that I want to ask you about.
他们大笑。他们使用那种广阔的、超出我们通常使用的术语的语言。它是“全开的”。它是“天哪”。我们哭泣。我们被带离了自我。你知道，Dacher，我想给你播放同一视频结尾的一段片段，因为它引出了我想问你的事情。
Oh, my God. What's it mean? Tell me. You know, it's interesting. Paul is almost uncomfortable by the intensity of the experience. He's struggling to understand what it means. And I think when most people think about,
“天哪。这意味着什么？告诉我。”你知道，这很有趣。Paul几乎因为体验的强度而感到不适。他在努力理解这意味着什么。我认为当大多数人想到
oh, they think about, okay, I'm seeing something beautiful. I see a beautiful sight, but I think we're getting into deeper waters here where awe can actually make us uncomfortable. Yeah, you know, awe destabilizes. It introduces profound uncertainty about our understanding of the world. It can be filled with threat. You know, when I sat amidst a storm, you know, I felt threatened. Just recently I was backpacking with my daughter Natalie, high sierras, and we got caught in a lightning storm. And it was awe-inspiring and threatening. and that is true, I believe, with Vasquez's experience, the double rainbow experience, you know, when we no longer can make sense of reality, which is a theme of all, it's that mystery, it's the need for finding new understandings of the world, often we feel adrift, we feel anxious, we feel threatened, and we feel destabilized.
敬畏时，他们想到的是，好吧，我看到了美丽的东西。我看到了美丽的景色，但我认为我们正在进入更深的水域，敬畏实际上会让我们感到不适。是的，你知道，敬畏会破坏稳定。它引入了关于我们对世界理解的深刻不确定性。它可能充满威胁。你知道，当我坐在风暴中时，你知道，我感到受到威胁。就在最近，我和女儿Natalie在内华达山脉背包旅行，我们被困在雷暴中。它既令人敬畏又具有威胁性。我相信Vasquez的经历也是如此，双彩虹的经历，你知道，当我们不再能理解现实时，这是敬畏的主题，那是奥秘，是需要寻找对世界的新理解，我们经常感到漂泊，感到焦虑，感到受到威胁，感到不稳定。
You found that another realm of experience that tends to inspire awe, involves other people who do amazing things. Tell me about the idea of moral beauty, Dachar. You know, moral beauty is the idea that other people's kindness and courage and overcoming obstacles and their virtuosity and their discipline can inspire us morally, where we see in them what we want to be as good human beings. And it astonished us, Shankar,
你发现另一种倾向于激发敬畏的体验领域涉及做惊人事情的他人。Dacher，告诉我关于“道德美”的想法。你知道，道德美是这样一种想法：他人的善良、勇气、克服障碍、他们的精湛技艺和纪律可以从道德上激励我们，我们在他们身上看到了我们作为好人想要成为的样子。Shankar，这让我们感到震惊，
at the Berkeley lab, that, you know, we sent out these requests, 26 countries, all these stories of awe come rolling in. And the most universal and the most common was the goodness or moral beauty of other people right around them. And I'm not talking about Mahat Mas Gandhi or Mother Teresa. It is like neighbors and strangers and grandmothers and the like and roommates that almost on a weekly basis are, triggering us to feel like, God, people are good.
在伯克利实验室，你知道，我们发出了这些请求，26个国家，所有这些敬畏的故事涌入。最普遍、最常见的是他们周围人的善良或道德美。我说的不是圣雄甘地或特蕾莎修女。就像邻居、陌生人、祖母之类的人，还有室友，几乎每周都在触发我们去感受，天哪，人是善良的。
And I could be inspired by that. I understand that you once had a powerful experience with a spiritual leader that also inspired a feeling of awe. Tell me about your encounter with the Dalai Lama. Hmm. It makes me humble to talk about it. You know, I've been on two panels with His Holiness, the Dalai Lama, and I'm like, man, I'm on a stage with the Dalai Lama.
我可以从中受到启发。我了解到你曾经与一位精神领袖有过一次强大的经历，这也激发了一种敬畏感。告诉我你与达赖喇嘛的相遇。嗯。谈论它让我感到谦卑。你知道，我和尊者达赖喇嘛一起参加过两个小组讨论，我当时想，天哪，我和达赖喇嘛在同一个舞台上。
and I'm like, man, I'm on a stage with the Dalai Lama, and there are 2,500 people out in the audience. Before we go on, I greet His Holiness. It's a profound moment. When he looks you in the eye, man, you feel like he is really looking me in the eye, and we hugged, and he kind of tickled me. And I was, and I literally, I was one giant goose bump. You know, I was like, wow, I've just hugged and been tickled by the Dalai Lama.
而且我当时想，天哪，我和达赖喇嘛在同一个舞台上，观众席里有2500人。在我们上台之前，我向尊者致意。这是一个深刻的时刻。当他看着你的眼睛时，伙计，你觉得他真的在看着我的眼睛，我们拥抱了，他甚至挠了我一下。我当时，我简直就是一个巨大的“鸡皮疙瘩”。你知道，我当时想，哇，我刚刚拥抱了达赖喇嘛，还被他挠了一下。
Then we go on stage. And, you know, and I'm asking him these dumb questions and, you know, the narrow scientists, and he's so engaged and interested and curious, you know, because he's training his mind in a way. He's working harder on his mind than I've ever worked on anything. And at one moment in this conversation, I'm asking him about compassion. And he says, compassion is the natural state of the mind. And I, you know, coming out of my Western scientific, homo-economics mindset, I was just. It was an epiphany, and epiphanies are a very subtle source of all where suddenly we grasp that there are big ideas that really make sense of a lot of things in reality. You might find epiphanies in the idea of free markets or evolution or that capitalism is bad for the planet or big data or the idea of quantum physics, right? And it's surprisingly common around the world and has this structure to seeing suddenly being revealed to big ideas
然后我们上台了。而且，你知道，我问他这些愚蠢的问题，你知道，狭隘的科学家，而他如此投入、感兴趣且好奇，你知道，因为他在以一种方式训练他的思想。他在思想上付出的努力比我在任何事情上付出的都要多。在这次谈话的某个时刻，我问他关于同情心的问题。他说，同情心是心灵的自然状态。而我，你知道，带着我西方的科学、“经济人”心态，我只是。那是一个顿悟，顿悟是一种非常微妙的敬畏来源，突然间我们领悟到有一些宏大的想法确实解释了现实中的许多事情。你可能会在自由市场、进化、资本主义对地球有害、大数据或量子物理学的想法中找到顿悟，对吧？这在世界各地令人惊讶地普遍，并且具有这种结构，即突然揭示出宏大的想法，
that help you make sense of the mysteries that concern you. And it was an awe moment, right? I was like, wait a minute. Compassion is the deepest structure in the human mind down in the midbrain, all these structures that have been part of mammalian evolution. And that animated a lot of research I did on compassion and changed how I teach.
帮助你理解困扰你的奥秘。那是一个敬畏的时刻，对吧？我当时想，等一下。同情心是人类心灵中最深层的结构，在中脑，所有这些作为哺乳动物进化一部分的结构。这激发了我所做的许多关于同情心的研究，并改变了我的教学方式。
And it changed how I thought about humanity, you know, that there is this deep goodness in us that's part of our evolutionary story. That's one of the most interesting parts of our evolutionary story, how good we are. And it blew my mind. You know, you talked about going to see Iggy Pop and then feeling like you could go on stage
它改变了我对人类的看法，你知道，我们内心深处有这种深层的善良，这是我们进化故事的一部分。这是我们进化故事中最有趣的部分之一，我们是多么善良。这让我大开眼界。你知道，你谈到去看Iggy Pop，然后感觉你可以上台
and talk to 300 students with newfound confidence. Did you find the same thing happened after meeting the Dalai Lama? Did your life feel different in the days and weeks that followed? After that experience with His Holiness the Dalai Lama, I felt like I had a deeper sense of purpose and meaning. And so, you know, I'm on an airplane, and I had profound flight anxiety. Every little bump felt like the end of my life. I'd have images of losing my life and my children and so forth.
和300名学生交谈，带着新的自信。你发现见到达赖喇嘛后也发生了同样的事情吗？在随后的几天和几周里，你的生活感觉不同了吗？在与尊者达赖喇嘛的那次经历之后，我觉得我有了更深的目标感和意义感。所以，你知道，我在飞机上，我有严重的飞行焦虑。每一个小颠簸都感觉像是生命的终结。我会产生失去生命和孩子之类的画面。
And I noticed that I wasn't anxious on the flight. I didn't need to power down a whiskey to make it home, you know. And then I got there and I was at the carousel, and of course my luggage was lost. and I literally laughed it off and I think I said, good, you know. It's time to shed all that stuff. I truly felt, and this is true of the science of awe, which is the mundane things don't get to you as much,
我注意到我在飞行中并不焦虑。我不需要喝威士忌来回家，你知道。然后我到了那里，我在行李传送带旁，当然我的行李丢了。我真的笑了出来，我想我说，很好，你知道。是时候摆脱所有那些东西了。我真的感觉到了，敬畏的科学也是如此，即平凡的事情不会那么影响你，
and I felt above them and strong. So I think, you know, all of us have had these experiences where we have that warm glow we get from, you know, an encounter with an awe-inspiring person or an experience. Is there any risk, attacker, that this can act, you know, like a kind of drug, that we get a high from feeling awestruck and inspired, and then this can lead us to be complacent or even oblivious to the sorrows or horrors of the world? Yeah, I think there are many risks of awe, right?
我感到超越了它们，并且很强大。所以我认为，你知道，我们所有人都经历过那些时刻，我们从与一个令人敬畏的人或经历的相遇中获得那种温暖的光芒。Dacher，有没有任何风险，你知道，这可以像一种毒品一样，我们从感到敬畏和受启发中获得快感，然后这可能导致我们变得自满，甚至对世界的悲伤或恐怖视而不见？是的，我认为敬畏有很多风险，对吧？
This is a destabilizing emotion. It leads you to look for new knowledge to make sense of the world. It leads you to abandon past knowledge structures, perhaps, or assumptions. And, you know, a parent might think of, well, that's what happened to my job. daughter when she joined a cult, as this cult leader suddenly persuaded her to abandon life and follow this new awe-inspiring figure. You know, there's a new concern in the psychedelic movement of for certain people who find too much, you know, destabilizing search for new meaning in psychedelic experiences that can get them into trouble. You could go on. Pierre Carlo Valdezolo
这是一种破坏稳定的情绪。它引导你去寻找新知识来理解世界。它引导你放弃过去的知识结构，也许，或者假设。而且，你知道，一位家长可能会想到，嗯，我女儿加入邪教时就是这样，因为这个邪教领袖突然说服她放弃生活，追随这个新的令人敬畏的人物。你知道，迷幻药运动中有一个新的担忧，对于某些发现太多，你知道，在迷幻体验中破坏稳定的新意义追求的人，这可能会让他们陷入麻烦。你可以继续说。Piercarlo Valdesolo
has, you know, nice study showing that certain kinds of awe make a sea. kind of patterns where there aren't patterns. And so we can believe things. You know, maybe a QAnon supporter feels goosebumps and awe at these stories that are absolute nonsense. They don't have a sense of boundaries. They enter into dangerous situations. So, yeah, there are risks here that we should be attentive to. As there are, Shankar, with every human passion. So you've become increasingly interested in the evolutionary origin. of awe, why is it that we would have an emotion like this? You know, it's possible that other species also experience awe, but of course, you know, we don't typically see a line of cats
有，你知道，很好的研究表明，某些类型的敬畏会让人看到不存在的模式。所以我们可以相信一些事情。你知道，也许一个QAnon支持者在这些绝对是胡说八道的故事中感到鸡皮疙瘩和敬畏。他们没有界限感。他们进入危险的情况。所以，是的，这里有我们应该注意的风险。正如Shankar，每一种人类激情都有风险一样。所以你对敬畏的进化起源越来越感兴趣，为什么我们会有一种这样的情绪？你知道，其他物种也可能经历敬畏，但当然，你知道，我们通常不会看到一排猫
sitting and watching a sunset together, right? It just doesn't happen. So is there something that might explain our predisposition to awe from an evolutionary perspective? You know, this is where the science of awe gets really interesting, which is how far back in our primate mammalian evolution can we trace this, right, if it is a basic emotion. And we have a lot of data that suggests awe is as basic to humanity and the human species is anger or fear. And we have a lot of data on the expression of awe
坐在一起看日落，对吧？这根本不会发生。那么有什么东西可以从进化的角度解释我们对敬畏的倾向吗？你知道，这就是敬畏科学变得非常有趣的地方，即如果它是一种基本情绪，我们可以在我们的灵长类哺乳动物进化中追溯到多远，对吧？我们有很多数据表明，敬畏对人类和人类物种来说就像愤怒或恐惧一样基本。我们有很多关于敬畏表达的数据，
and what it does to our social behavior and sense of self that awe is this pretty deep human universal emotion. And I think that it does two things that are vital to our evolution. And the first is it connects the individual to collectives. And time and time again, when people experience all, they say things like I felt small and I felt like I was part of something larger than myself. And this is fundamental to our survival. And then the other thing that I think is really important, Shanker, is that awe helps us see the systems around us and understand them. One of the sets of operations of our mind is to be very narrow and focus on the self and
以及它对我们的社会行为和自我意识的影响，敬畏是一种非常深刻的人类普遍情绪。我认为它做了两件对我们进化至关重要的事情。第一是它将个体与集体连接起来。一次又一次，当人们经历敬畏时，他们会说“我感到渺小，我感到自己是比我自身更大的事物的一部分”。这对我们的生存至关重要。然后我认为另一件非常重要的事情，Shankar，是敬畏帮助我们看到周围的系统并理解它们。我们大脑的一组操作是变得非常狭隘，专注于自我和
individual actions and cause and effect relationships. The other is to look at the world holistically and systemically. That's an ecosystem. This is a social hierarchy. That is a musical structure. And awe pops those systems out to our awareness. So it really is the animator of a system's view of life. And that's really important for scientific understanding.
个体行为以及因果关系。另一组是整体地、系统地看待世界。那是一个生态系统。这是一个社会等级。那是一个音乐结构。而敬畏将这些系统弹出到我们的意识中。所以它确实是系统生活观的推动者。这对科学理解非常重要，
for social understanding, for knowing where to find resources in my environment, right, to understand my ecology. And awe is the great engine of a system's view of the world. You know, and so much of it begins with the feeling that awe can produce in us of making us feel small. I remember visiting Alaska once and feeling like I was a very small creature on a very, very big planet. And you've done studies looking at the same idea. you ran an interesting study in Yosemite, exploring this idea that odd changes our sense of our own scale.
对社会理解，对知道在我的环境中哪里可以找到资源，对吧，去理解我的生态。而敬畏是系统世界观的伟大引擎。你知道，其中很大一部分始于敬畏能在我们内心产生的一种让我们感到渺小的感觉。我记得有一次去阿拉斯加，感觉自己是一个非常大的星球上一个非常小的生物。你也做过研究，探讨了同样的想法。你在优胜美地进行了一项有趣的研究，探索了敬畏改变我们对自己规模感知的想法。
You know, the self takes up a lot of area in the brain and in our consciousness. We're always thinking, especially in this modern world, about my goals, my status, my aspirations, what I'm doing. It's my desires, my interests. And evolutionists have really talked about the problem of self-interest. How do we get people to orient to other people, to societies and collectives? And we started to have this idea that awe does that by creating the small self. In a lot of writings about awe, religious writings from centuries ago, nature writings, Ralph Waldo Emerson, his big epiphany, I am nothing, right?
你知道，自我在大脑和我们的意识中占据了很大的区域。我们总是，特别是在这个现代世界，思考关于我的目标、我的地位、我的抱负、我在做什么。这是我的欲望，我的兴趣。进化论者确实谈到了自私的问题。我们如何让人们面向他人、社会和集体？我们开始有这种想法，即敬畏通过创造“小我”来做到这一点。在许多关于敬畏的著作中，几个世纪前的宗教著作、自然著作，拉尔夫·沃尔多·爱默生，他伟大的顿悟，“我什么都不是”，对吧？
Psychedelic writings. All these writings are speaking to this, but we had to get it empirically. So my collaborator, Yang Bai, from China, went to Yosemite, stopped travelers from 42 countries at this particular outlook on a road where you first get to see Yosemite Valley and El Capitan and the Great Granite Slabs and this incredible valley that's just awe-inspiring. And what Yang Bai did is she did a really simple task.
迷幻著作。所有这些著作都在谈论这一点，但我们必须通过经验来获得它。所以我的合作者，来自中国的白杨，去了优胜美地，在路上这个特定的观景点拦住了来自42个国家的旅行者，在那里你第一次能看到优胜美地山谷、酋长岩、巨大的花岗岩板和这个令人敬畏的不可思议的山谷。白杨所做的是一个非常简单的任务。
She had people at that moment draw themselves and write me. And in that context, those drawings of the self were really small. They wrote their sense of me, really small compared to the right kind of control conditions. And we have other data and really different kinds of data, even neuroscientific data showing awe quiets this egoistic, self-focused sense of personal identity and opens you up to the big things that you're connected to. You and your collaborator Lani Shioda
她在那一刻让人们画出自己并写下“我”。在那种背景下，那些自我的画真的很小。与正确的控制条件相比，他们写下的“我”的意识真的很小。我们还有其他数据和非常不同类型的数据，甚至是神经科学数据，显示敬畏使这种利己的、以自我为中心的个人身份感安静下来，并让你向你所连接的宏大事物敞开。你和你的合作者Lani Shiota
also once had people stand in front of an enormous T-Rex skeleton. Tell me about that experiment, Ducker. On the Berkeley campus, we have this incredible replica of a T-Rex skeleton and it's in our Museum of Paleontology and you stand next to it. And we did the pilot testing. People say, I feel awe, man, this is amazing. It's huge. Imagine being chased by that thing, you know?
也曾经让人们站在一个巨大的霸王龙骨架前。Dacher，告诉我那个实验。在伯克利校园里，我们有这个不可思议的霸王龙骨架复制品，它在我们的古生物学博物馆里，你站在它旁边。我们做了试点测试。人们说，我感到敬畏，伙计，这太神奇了。它太大了。想象一下被那个东西追赶，你知道？
Wow, those things existed 70 million years ago? It's awesome. So Lonnie and our team stood Berkeley undergraduates by this T-Rex, or they stood in the opposite direction looking down a hallway. And there's this classic measure of your own self or identity, which is you are given the STEM, I am, and next to it is a blank line, and you just fill it in. 20 different times.
哇，那些东西在7000万年前就存在了？这太棒了。所以Lonnie和我们的团队让伯克利本科生站在这个霸王龙旁边，或者让他们朝相反的方向看走廊。有一个经典的衡量你自己或身份的方法，就是给你“我是”这个词干，旁边是一条空白线，你只需填上它。20次。
And typically people living in the West will say things like, I am extroverted and I am ambitious and I am interested in this and I have and when they stood next to that T-Rex and took it in and felt awe,
通常生活在西方的人会说诸如“我是外向的”、“我是雄心勃勃的”、“我对这个感兴趣”之类的话，而当他们站在那只霸王龙旁边并感受敬畏时，
their sense of self expanded and themes of common humanity emerged. I am a human, I am a mammal, I am a part of California, I am of this ethnic variety. And so this collective communal self emerged. And that's the power of all. A little moment, 30 seconds of it, you shift from self-focused, very narrow, to, wow, I'm part of something really large.
他们的自我意识扩展了，共同人性的主题出现了。我是人类，我是哺乳动物，我是加州的一部分，我是这个种族多样性的一部分。所以这种集体性的公共自我出现了。这就是敬畏的力量。一个小小的时刻，30秒，你就从以自我为中心、非常狭隘，转变为，哇，我是非常宏大的事物的一部分。
And some of this translates not just to how we think about ourselves in our own minds, but how we're acting towards other people. You also ran another experiment on the Berkeley campus, this time involving a grow of eucalyptus trees. me about that study, Daco. Yeah, you know, one of the beauties of awe and to understand it, it brings out the best of our imagination, you know. And my lab started to get interested in awe, and we were throwing around all these ideas
其中一些不仅转化为我们如何在自己的大脑中思考自己，还转化为我们如何对待他人。你还在伯克利校园进行了另一项实验，这次涉及一片桉树林。Dacher，告诉我那个研究。是的，你知道，敬畏的美丽之处之一，去理解它，它激发了我们想象力中最好的一面，你知道。我的实验室开始对敬畏感兴趣，我们一直在抛出所有这些想法
and doing these crazy studies. And the very imaginative Paul Piff, now professor at UC Irvine, did a study in which he took undergrads to a eucalyptus grove and their blue gum eucalyptus trees. some of the tallest in North America. When you look up into them, their light and the colors and the leaves
并做这些疯狂的研究。非常有想象力的Paul Piff，现在是加州大学欧文分校的教授，做了一项研究，他带本科生去了一片桉树林，那是蓝桉树。北美最高的树木之一。当你抬头看它们时，它们的光线、颜色和叶子
and their fragrances are just astonishing. That grove, when you stand in the middle of them, embraces you. It makes you feel like you're part of them. And in the control condition, people are in the same place, but they looked at this science building. And lo and behold, you know, Shankar, this is a minute or two of just for no reason looking up into these trees. In one to two minutes, our students reported feeling less narcissistic, less entitled.
以及它们的香气简直令人惊叹。那片树林，当你站在它们中间时，拥抱了你。它让你觉得你是它们的一部分。在控制条件下，人们在同一个地方，但他们看着这栋科学大楼。瞧，你知道，Shankar，这只是一两分钟无缘无故地抬头看着这些树。在一到两分钟内，我们的学生报告说感觉不那么自恋，不那么自以为是。
They needed less money to do the study when we offered to pay them. And then Paul staged this accident where a student was walking by and they dropped some pens and the people feeling awe picked up more pens, right? And we replicated that in tightly controlled laboratory studies. you just share more when you're feeling awe, you cooperate more, you give more, just with a minute or two of looking up at some trees. You know, very much like you described about your own experiences in Wisconsin, you and Jonathan Haidt have said that an experience of awe can press a reset button in the mind. What do you mean by that, Decker? Reset buttons are really interesting.
当我们提出为他们提供报酬时，他们进行这项研究所需的资金就减少了。然后，保罗策划了一场意外，让一名学生路过时掉落了一些钢笔，而那些感受到敬畏感的人捡起了更多的钢笔，对吧？我们在严格控制的实验室研究中复制了这一结果。当你感到敬畏时，你会更乐于分享，更愿意合作，给予更多，仅仅是因为抬头看了几分钟树木。你知道，这和你描述自己在威斯康星州的经历非常相似，你和乔纳森·海特都说过，敬畏的体验可以按下心灵的重置键。你这话是什么意思，戴克？重置键确实很有趣。
And actually, you know, Sylvan Tompkins wrote about when you're startled by a loud clap of thunder or the appearance of an old friend or bumping into a friend in the street, it kind of restarts your mind. It resets it to look at things anew and fresh and contemplative people might say with a beginner's mind. And that's what awe does for a Shanker. When we come back, how to bring more awe into our lives. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. At UC Berkeley, psychologist Dakar Keltner studies the benevolent emotions, including the emotion of awe. He's the author of the book, Aw, the New Science of Everyday Wonder, and How It Can Transform Your Life.
事实上，你知道，西尔万·汤姆金斯曾写道，当你被一声响亮的雷鸣吓到，或者看到一位老朋友，或是在街上偶遇朋友时，这会重启你的思维。它将你的思维重置，让你以全新的、新鲜的视角看待事物，沉思者可能会说这是以“初学者的心态”来看待。这就是敬畏对我们所做的。稍后回来，我们将探讨如何将更多的敬畏感带入我们的生活。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在加州大学伯克利分校，心理学家戴克·凯尔特纳研究仁慈的情绪，包括敬畏感。他是《敬畏：日常奇迹的新科学及其如何改变你的生活》一书的作者。
Dacker, you recently studied the effects of awe on disadvantaged students and military veterans, neither felt much awe in their regular lives. What did you do? What did the study involve? Yeah, you know, there's a growing interest in our culture and scientifically about how the institutional, structural traumas of life, if you're impoverished and you don't have parks nearby and the like, or you have a career like veterans who go see combat and see people die, their profiles look traumatized. They are depressed and vigilant, anxious very often, twice the rates of American citizens,
戴克，你最近研究了敬畏对弱势学生和退伍军人的影响，他们两人在日常生活中都没有感受到太多的敬畏。你做了什么？这项研究涉及什么？是的，你知道，我们的文化和科学界对生活的制度性、结构性创伤越来越感兴趣，比如如果你生活贫困，附近没有公园之类的地方，或者像退伍军人那样经历过战斗并目睹人们死亡，他们的心理状况看起来就像是受过创伤。他们经常感到抑郁、警觉、焦虑，比例是普通美国公民的两倍，
elevated levels of cortisol and inflammation and the like. And I became friends with Stacey Bear, who's a veteran, and we started talking about this. He leads veterans into outdoors programs. And so what we decided to do in this study is we got veterans and high school students who were in really tough, impoverished schools in parts of the East Bay in California. And it's, you know, where there are bars and police cars and no gardens, et cetera. And these kids hadn't, you know, been.
皮质醇和炎症水平升高等等。我和斯泰西·贝尔成为了朋友，他是一名退伍军人，我们开始谈论这件事。他带领退伍军人参加户外项目。所以我们决定在这项研究中做的是，我们找来了退伍军人和加州东湾地区一些非常艰苦、贫困学校的高中生。你知道，那里到处是酒吧、警车，没有花园等等。这些孩子以前并没有，你知道，去过
outside in parks. They hadn't gone camping. Many of them had not really seen a night sky of stars. So we took them rafting. Our veterans and then our high schoolers down the American river on a stretch and it's beautiful and you wind through these rapids and you look at the water and you see fish and it's amazing. And what we found, we measured their emotions, and stress and trauma and sense of connection at the start of the study, a week later. And as the study unfolded, we measured their sense of wonder
公园外面。他们没有去过露营。他们中的许多人甚至没有真正见过满天繁星的夜空。所以我们带他们去漂流。我们的退伍军人和高中生沿着美国河的一段水域漂流，那里很美，你穿过这些急流，看着水流，看到鱼，这太神奇了。我们测量了他们的情绪、压力、创伤和研究开始时以及一周后的联系感。随着研究的展开，我们测量了他们的惊奇感
and awe and connection to their peers and cortisol and emotions. And what we found is our high schoolers, a week later, felt less stress, more happiness, they felt more connected to their community and family. And our veterans felt 30% less PTSD. one high schooler said I'm so struck by the rolling hills and the smoke and it was smoky at the time because of wildfires and the water and then a veteran said and I love this quote where you know the star splatted sky made me realize that my worries are not as important as I thought they are but what I could do in the world is more important and so it was this nice study and there's a lot of science on this of different
和敬畏感，以及与同伴的联系、皮质醇和情绪。我们发现，一周后，我们的高中生压力减轻了，幸福感增强了，他们感到与社区和家庭的联系更紧密了。而我们的退伍军人的创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）减轻了30%。一位高中生说，我被连绵起伏的丘陵和烟雾深深震撼了，当时因为野火到处都是烟雾，还有水。然后一位退伍军人说，我喜欢这句话，他说，星光点点的天空让我意识到，我的烦恼并不像我想象的那么重要，而我在世界上能做的事情才更重要。所以这是一项很好的研究，关于不同种类的科学研究有很多，
varieties that nature immersion and finding awe, gardening, walking, getting out into the woods, standing near a tree is good for your nervous system and your mind. Is there any evidence that awe has physiological effects on us? Yeah, there are, you know, there's this thing called the vagus nerve, largest bundle of nerves in your body. It slows heart rate, deepens breathing, regulates digestion, helps with your gut in the microbiome, in general, people have a nice functioning vagus nerve that is responsive and has elevated levels do better in life. And we found, thanks to Amy Gordon and Jenny stellar, you know, that little brief experiences of awe, seeing an inspiring image, hearing about
沉浸在自然中并寻找敬畏感，园艺、散步、走进树林、站在树旁，对你的神经系统和心灵都有好处。有没有证据表明敬畏对我们有生理影响？是的，有，你知道，有一种东西叫迷走神经，它是你体内最大的神经束。它能减缓心率、加深呼吸、调节消化、帮助肠道微生物群。总的来说，迷走神经功能良好且反应灵敏的人，生活得更好。多亏了艾米·戈登和珍妮·斯特拉，我们发现，短暂的敬畏体验，比如看到一张鼓舞人心的图片，听到关于
moral beauty, elevates your vagus nerve activation. And then just as impressively, you know, when your immune system, the cytokine system, more specifically, cranks out these proteins that attack pathogens, and that's the inflammation response that makes you feel feverish and sluggish and overheated. It's good when you're fighting a virus. It's not good if you're chronically inflamed, and it's one of the central threats to health in the United States. And Jenny Stellar and Nihaha John Henderson went out and found in our lab
道德之美，会提升你的迷走神经激活水平。同样令人印象深刻的是，你知道，当你的免疫系统，更具体地说是细胞因子系统，产生这些攻击病原体的蛋白质时，这就是让你感到发烧、迟钝和过热的炎症反应。当你对抗病毒时，这是好事。但如果你长期处于炎症状态，那就不是好事了，这是美国健康面临的核心威胁之一。珍妮·斯特拉和尼哈·约翰·亨德森在我们的实验室里发现
that feeling a lot of awe of all the positive emotions quiets down the inflammation response. So it tells us, you know, Emerson, when he had this big epiphany of awe out on a cold day in Massachusetts, he said there is nothing that nature cannot repair. And I think he was feeling these changes in the body of vagal tone and inflammation,
感受到强烈的敬畏感，在所有积极情绪中，能平息炎症反应。所以这告诉我们，你知道，爱默生在马萨诸塞州一个寒冷的日子里产生这种巨大的敬畏顿悟时，他说没有什么东西是自然无法修复的。我认为他当时感受到了身体中迷走神经张力和炎症的变化，
reduced inflammation, that awe gives us. So, Dr. You've described many ways in which awe is good for us, but you've also said that our society is becoming awe-deprived. What do you mean by that? The deeper structural conditions of our lives are in some ways, especially for young people today, working against awe. And I really sense this teaching thousands of students a year at a big university like Berkeley,
敬畏带给我们的炎症减轻。所以，戴克，你描述了许多敬畏对我们有益的方式，但你也说过我们的社会正变得“敬畏匮乏”。你这话是什么意思？我们生活的更深层的结构性条件在某些方面，特别是对今天的年轻人来说，正在阻碍敬畏感的产生。我在伯克利这样的大型大学每年教导成千上万的学生，我真的感觉到了这一点，
they are awe-deprived because too much is structured and they are not allowed to wander, like I did as a kid, wandering around the neighborhoods and out into the foothills. They are awe-deprived because of the new technologies, which frankly just get us too focused on the self. The more we're focused on the self, the narrow parts of the self, the less awe-we feel they're awe-deprived
他们缺乏敬畏感，因为太多的东西被结构化了，他们不被允许像我小时候那样去漫游，在社区里闲逛，走到山脚下。由于新技术，他们缺乏敬畏感，坦率地说，这些技术让我们太专注于自我。我们越专注于自我，专注于自我的狭隘部分，我们感受到的敬畏就越少。他们缺乏敬畏感，
because of all the competitive self-comparisons that have arisen today. So are people getting enough of it? No. We need more awe right now. You know, Lancet publication recently showed that the pandemic has led to rises in depression and anxiety by 20 to 30 percent. We've all felt this, our young people in particular.
因为今天出现了各种竞争性的自我比较。那么人们得到足够的敬畏感了吗？没有。我们现在需要更多的敬畏感。你知道，《柳叶刀》最近发表的一项研究显示，疫情导致抑郁和焦虑增加了20%到30%。我们都感受到了这一点，尤其是我们的年轻人。
But there is everyday awe. And if we just take a little moment to get out and look for it, It's there to find. So, Dr. in one recent study, you had volunteers take an awe walk. What is an awe walk? One of the easiest ways to find awe is to, in an unbounded way, go out and walk. We have been doing this as humans for a long time in this spiritual, contemplative traditions.
但生活中处处有敬畏。如果我们花点时间走出去寻找它，它是可以被发现的。那么，戴克，在最近的一项研究中，你让志愿者进行了一次“敬畏漫步”。什么是敬畏漫步？寻找敬畏最简单的方法之一就是以一种不受束缚的方式走出去散步。作为人类，我们在精神和沉思的传统中已经这样做很长时间了。
Getting out into nature and doing all walks is just part. of those traditions. And what we decided to do is test its benefits scientifically. And so I wrote up these instructions for an awe walk. And what you do is you take your ordinary walk that a lot of people do.
走进大自然并进行敬畏漫步只是这些传统的一部分。我们决定从科学上测试它的好处。所以我写下了这些关于敬畏漫步的说明。你所做的就是进行许多人都会进行的普通散步。
And in fact, during the pandemic, there are historic levels of walking. And you not only go out to do it vigorously and to help your heart, but you go with a childlike sense of wonder and you just stop and reflect on what is really interesting in the small things around you, the flowers and patterns of shadows and like,
事实上，在疫情期间，人们的步行量达到了历史最高水平。你不仅是为了剧烈运动和帮助心脏健康而走，你还要带着一种孩子般的惊奇感去走，停下来反思你周围小事物中真正有趣的东西，比如花朵、影子的图案等等，
and also look up past the horizon and look up to the vast things, right? And do it in a way where you go places that you're curious about. And in this study, what we did is our participants were all 75 years old or older. That is an age where because we have a sense that death is coming and we see people die, we're a little bit more anxious at that stage of life. And so one group of our participants did an awe walk once a week for eight weeks. The other group of participants, tight control, did a vigorous walk once a week.
还要抬头看向地平线之外，看向广阔的事物，对吧？并且以一种去你好奇的地方的方式去走。在这项研究中，我们所做的是，我们的参与者年龄都在75岁或以上。这是一个因为我们感觉到死亡即将来临，看到人们离世，所以在这个人生阶段会感到更加焦虑的年龄。因此，我们的一组参与者每周进行一次敬畏漫步，持续八周。另一组参与者作为严格对照组，每周进行一次剧烈运动步行。
Each time they did a walk, they took a picture of themselves, and then we gathered a bunch of self-reports, like how are they doing on a daily basis, how is their levels of anxiety and so forth. And we found just a couple of things. One, the more you do the awe-walk, the more awe-inspiring it becomes. Aw doesn't diminish with experience, it gets richer and deeper. By the end of the eight weeks, our aw-walk participants were feeling a lot of awe.
每次散步时，他们都会给自己拍张照片，然后我们收集了一堆自我报告，比如他们每天的情况如何，焦虑水平如何等等。我们发现了几件事。第一，你进行敬畏漫步的次数越多，它就越能激发敬畏感。敬畏不会随着经验而减少，它会变得更丰富、更深刻。到八周结束时，我们的敬畏漫步参与者感受到了强烈的敬畏感。
Two, more changes in the self. There are pictures of themselves, and I love this finding. The self gets smaller over time, and it starts to drift off to the side, and they're including, you know, the rocks and sunsets of their awlwalk. And then third, really importantly, on a daily basis, they just felt less distress. You know, they felt less anxiety about life. You know, in many ways in this conversation, Dhaka,
第二，自我的更多变化。有他们自己的照片，我喜欢这个发现。随着时间的推移，自我变得更小了，开始向一侧漂移，他们把敬畏漫步中看到的岩石和日落也包含进去了。第三，非常重要的一点是，在日常生活中，他们感到的痛苦减少了。你知道，他们对生活的焦虑感减少了。你知道，在这次谈话中，戴克，
we've spent a lot of time talking about awe in the beautiful and the majestic, but you've written that so much of life is awesome, the parts that are not great. Tell me about your relationship with your brother, Rolf. You were very close to him, right? Yeah, you know, just hearing you say his name brings goosebumps and tears to me. He was born one year after me, so he was younger, and we did everything together. We played little league together. We played basketball teams together, wandered together, went to Mexico together, were best men in each other's weddings. We both became social science-y teacher types. And frankly, he taught me how to be kinder and how to be
我们花了很多时间谈论美丽和宏伟中的敬畏，但你写道，生活中有太多东西是令人敬畏的，包括那些并不美好的部分。告诉我你和你兄弟罗尔夫的关系。你们很亲近，对吧？是的，你知道，听到你叫他的名字，我就会起鸡皮疙瘩，热泪盈眶。他比我小一岁，所以他更年轻，我们什么都一起做。我们一起参加小联盟，一起打篮球队，一起漫游，一起去墨西哥，在彼此的婚礼上担任伴郎。我们都成了社会科学类的教师。坦率地说，他教会了我如何更善良，如何更
courageous. I don't think I was endowed with those tendencies early. He taught me. He was my example in many ways of moral beauty. So I was profoundly close to him through the ebbs and flows of brotherhood, but he was my core. So I understand a few years ago, he was diagnosed with colon cancer. Tell me about that, Dacre. Anyone out listening, you know, who's been close to colon cancer, it's a horror show. And for my brother, for two years, I watched him, you know, go from being a 210-pound, very strong man, 147 pounds, bone thin, passing out. There's a lot of pain, but there are certain kinds of pain that just wipe out consciousness, breakthrough pain, and abdominal pain is like that.
勇敢。我不认为我早期就具备这些倾向。是他教会了我。在许多方面，他是道德美的榜样。所以，尽管兄弟情谊有起有落，但我与他非常亲近，他是我的核心。所以我知道几年前，他被诊断出患有结肠癌。告诉我这件事，戴克。任何在听的人，你知道，如果曾与结肠癌亲近过，那简直是一场噩梦。对于我兄弟来说，两年来，我看着他，你知道，从一个210磅、非常强壮的男人，变成147磅，瘦骨嶙峋，昏倒。有很多痛苦，但有些痛苦会直接抹去意识，突破性的疼痛，腹痛就是这样。
He got it all, chemotherapy, and I was just there all the time. And then he decided to take a cocktail when he knew the cancer had returned and headed into his gut. And we all went up there in January, and we watched him, you know, slowly leave this world. And Shanker, I had gone through the most horrifying two years of my life, watching my companion in awe, my brother Rolf, fade physically. But in that moment of seeing him calmer, heading into where he was going after losing his body, we were all around him, we touched him, the light felt different, we were quiet, we bowed our heads,
他经历了这一切，化疗，我一直都在那里。当他知道癌症复发并扩散到肠道时，他决定服用一种鸡尾酒疗法。一月份我们都去了那里，看着他，你知道，慢慢地离开这个世界。尚卡尔，我经历了人生中最可怕的两年，看着我的敬畏伙伴，我的兄弟罗尔夫，身体逐渐衰竭。但在那一刻，看到他平静下来，在失去身体后走向他要去的地方，我们都围在他身边，我们触摸他，光线感觉不同，我们保持安静，我们低下头，
and we were all in reverence of my brother Rolf and what he meant. And watching him go, I was filled with astonishment and awe. I understand that you took a trip to honor your brother's memories, after he died. Where did you go, Dachar? After he died, and then I returned to my life in Berkeley and was blown off the map. And it's really the state that Joan Didion describes, you know, in her writing about grief. I couldn't sleep and anxious and confused and was just really struggling. And this voice came to me, and it was find awe.
我们都对我的兄弟罗尔夫以及他所代表的意义怀有敬畏之心。看着他离去，我充满了惊奇和敬畏。我知道你在他去世后进行了一次旅行来纪念你的兄弟。你去哪儿了，戴克？在他去世后，我回到了伯克利的生活中，感觉天崩地裂。这确实是琼·狄迪恩在描写悲伤时所描述的状态。我无法入睡，焦虑且困惑，真的非常挣扎。然后一个声音传到我耳边，那就是“寻找敬畏”。
and my brother and I we always went to the mountains you know we grew up in the mountains near the sierras and I went up into the high sierras and ducks lake where he and I had hiked and mammoth in the east side of the sierras when I saw the ridge line that he and I had seen I felt him there
我和我兄弟总是去山里，你知道，我们在靠近内华达山脉的山区长大，我去了高海拔的内华达山脉和鸭子湖，那是他和我在东侧的猛犸象山徒步旅行过的地方。当我看到他和我都见过的山脊线时，我感觉他在那里，
I heard his voice I saw the trees that he and I had seen these trees flicker in the wind the aspen trees and I just felt him there Shankar It's like, in these mountains, my brother is with me. Dacker Keltner is a psychologist at the University of California, Berkeley. He's the author of All, the new science of everyday wonder, and how it can transform your life.
我听到了他的声音，我看到了我和他见过的树木，这些树木在风中摇曳，那是白杨树，我只是感觉到他在那里。尚卡尔，就像在这些山里，我的兄弟和我在一起。戴克·凯尔特纳是加州大学伯克利分校的心理学家。他是《敬畏：日常奇迹的新科学及其如何改变你的生活》一书的作者。
Dachar, thank you for joining me today on Hidden Brain. Shankar, it is a privilege to be in conversation with you. Thank you. When we come back, your questions answered. Mary Helen Imordino-Yang responds to listeners' thoughts and stories about learning and what she calls transcendent thinking. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantham. There's more than one way to learn how to read and write. But if you grow up in the US in the 1950s,
戴克，感谢你今天参加《隐藏的大脑》。尚卡尔，能与你交谈是我的荣幸。谢谢。稍后回来，我们将回答你的问题。玛丽·海伦·伊莫迪诺-杨将回应听众关于学习以及她所称的“超越性思维”的想法和故事。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。学习读写的方法不止一种。但如果你是在20世纪50年代的美国长大，
Your classes may have unfolded something like this. As part of the reading readiness program, children are trained to look from left to right. This is from a documentary released in 1956. Children are sitting in rows of desks. They are staring up at their teacher. She walks them through reading and writing techniques. Phonics and the alphabet help children learn to spell.
你的课堂可能就是这样进行的。作为阅读准备计划的一部分，孩子们被训练从左向右看。这是1956年发布的一部纪录片。孩子们坐在成排的课桌前。他们抬头盯着老师。她引导他们学习阅读和写作技巧。拼音和字母表帮助孩子们学习拼写。
Patty is arranging words in alphabetical order. Danny is dividing them into syllables. Kenneth is placing the accent marks. Knowledge flows in one direction from teacher to students. There's an emphasis on rules and memorization. Deanna and Wilder know they must practice just as their parents and grandparents did to memorize the number of facts. This kind of teaching was the standard for a long time, in the U.S. and elsewhere,
帕蒂正在按字母顺序排列单词。丹尼正在把它们分成音节。肯尼斯正在标注重音符号。知识从老师流向学生，单向流动。重点在于规则和死记硬背。迪安娜和怀尔德知道，他们必须像他们的父母和祖父母那样练习，才能记住这些事实。这种教学方式在很长一段时间里，无论是在美国还是其他地方，都是标准，
and continues in many classrooms today. But in more recent years, many educators and schools have embraced alternative approaches to learning. Experiential learning, problem-based learning, project-based learning, flipped classrooms, whole-child education. All of these approaches attempt to upend the traditional model of teaching. At the University of Southern California, psychologist and neuroscientist Mary Helen Imordino-Yan, says any educational approach should start not with the material being taught, it should start with a student. Mary Helen was a guest on a recent episode of Hidden Brain titled How Our Brains Learn.
并且在今天的许多教室里仍在继续。但近年来，许多教育工作者和学校已经开始采用替代性的学习方法。体验式学习、基于问题的学习、基于项目的学习、翻转课堂、全人教育。所有这些方法都试图颠覆传统的教学模式。在南加州大学，心理学家兼神经科学家玛丽·海伦·伊莫迪诺-杨表示，任何教育方法都不应从所教的材料开始，而应从学生开始。玛丽·海伦是《隐藏的大脑》最近一期节目《我们的大脑如何学习》的嘉宾。
Today, we bring her back on the show to answer your questions about the science of learning. Mary Helen Imordino-Yang, welcome back to Hidden Brain. Thank you for having me back. Mary Helen, I'd like to start with the message we received from a listener named Rashid. it had to do with a learning experience that resonated with him for all the wrong reasons. In sixth grade, my mom signed me up for swimming lessons because I didn't know how to swim. And until then, I'd always been a straight-A student. So I figured with a little hard work, a little application, I would get another A.
今天，我们请她回到节目中，回答你们关于学习科学的问题。玛丽·海伦·伊莫迪诺-杨，欢迎回到《隐藏的大脑》。谢谢你邀请我回来。玛丽·海伦，我想从我们收到的一位名叫拉希德的听众发来的信息开始。这与他的一次学习经历有关，那次经历因各种错误的原因引起了他的共鸣。六年级时，我妈妈给我报了游泳课，因为我不会游泳。在那之前，我一直是个全A学生。所以我心想，只要稍微努力一点，稍微应用一下，我就能再拿一个A。
But I struggled the whole time and ended up not knowing how to swim even at the end of the class. And so the teacher gave me an F, and then even shrugged and said, well, you didn't learn how to swim. swim. And I have to admit that that hit me a little hard because it was my first F, first non-A, and my mom didn't really pay him to grade me. She paid him to teach me. And it really made me question the whole system, right? So learning how to swim is not the same as learning how to read or do multiplication, but what I'm struck by here is that the teacher told Rashid, you didn't learn how to swim. In other words, the fault was with Rashid. Now, we don't know all the particulars of this particular case, Mary Helen, but how could this teacher have
但我全程都很挣扎，到课程结束时还是没学会游泳。于是老师给了我一个F，甚至耸耸肩说，好吧，你没学会游泳。我不得不承认，这对我打击很大，因为这是我第一个F，第一个非A，而且我妈妈付钱给他并不是为了让他给我打分。她是付钱让他教我。这真的让我质疑整个系统，对吧？所以学习游泳和学习阅读或乘法是不一样的，但我在这里感到震惊的是，老师告诉拉希德，你没学会游泳。换句话说，错在拉希德。现在，我们不知道这个特定案例的所有细节，玛丽·海伦，但这位老师本可以
approached the situation differently? Well, first, I'm so sorry, Rashid, I feel your pain. I think too many of us have had experiences like this in settings that are meant to be, you know, developmental, that are meant to be enriching and enjoyable and opportunities to really learn something new that's a useful skill that you are wanting to have. That's a new. And for you, sounds like something of risk you've never done before, right? Something new. And then, you know, you were sort of judged by someone else as having been a failure, right? Like literally, F. So I think the teacher came to it with the idea that the purpose of swimming lessons is for you to be able to swim on the last day, which is in a sense, true.
如何以不同的方式处理这种情况？嗯，首先，我很抱歉，拉希德，我感同身受。我认为我们中有太多人在本应是发展性的、本应是丰富和愉快的、本应是真正学习新技能的机会的环境中，有过这样的经历，这些技能是你想要拥有的。那是新的。对你来说，听起来像是你从未做过的冒险，对吧？新鲜事物。然后，你知道，你被别人评判为失败了，对吧？就像字面上的F。所以我认为老师带着这样的想法来到这里：游泳课的目的是让你在最后一天能够游泳，这在某种意义上是真的。
But the question is not just what's the output. It's what's the process? And there, I think the teacher has totally missed the point. You know, Rashid's question is making me reflect on the fact, Mary Helen, that throughout the educational system, you know, teachers teach students, but then they grade students. And of course, at some level, this seems intuitively obvious. This is what teachers do. You grade the student to see if the student has mastered the material. But at some level, every one of these interactions is a little bit like what Rashid was talking about, which is that at the end of the day, the teacher is asking, have you learned the material, as opposed to asking, have I managed to engage you with the material? successfully bring you in into the process of learning. Yeah. And I would say even more than that, the most immediate question that teacher is asking or should be asking is, how have you been engaging with this material as I've been facilitating your invitation into it? What has the thought process been like for you? And how can I shape the context that we're in together in a way
但问题不仅仅是产出是什么。过程是什么？在那里，我认为老师完全没抓住重点。你知道，拉希德的问题让我反思这样一个事实，玛丽·海伦，在整个教育系统中，你知道，老师教学生，但随后他们给学生打分。当然，在某种程度上，这似乎是直觉上显而易见的。这就是老师所做的。你给学生打分，看看学生是否掌握了材料。但在某种程度上，每一次这样的互动都有点像拉希德所说的，即归根结底，老师问的是，你学会了材料吗，而不是问，我是否成功地让你参与到材料中？成功地把你带入学习的过程中。是的。而且我会说，甚至不止于此，老师正在问或应该问的最直接的问题是，当我促进你进入这个过程时，你是如何与这些材料互动的？对你来说，思维过程是怎样的？我怎样才能塑造我们在一起的环境，以一种
that will invite you to make the most productive, enjoyable use of this opportunity possible. So the central idea that we talked about in our earlier discussion, Mary Haddon, was a concept that you called transcendent thinking. For listeners who miss the earlier conversation or have forgotten the details, what is transcendent thinking? Yeah. So we're calling this thing transcendent thinking because it's our natural proclivity to start to make deeper meaning out of the things we're witnessing, to try to understand and grapple with the why, the how come, the how else. What is the history of this? What's the story behind it?
能邀请你尽可能高效、愉快地利用这个机会的方式。所以我们在之前的讨论中谈到的核心思想，玛丽·海伦，是一个你称之为超越性思维的概念。对于错过之前对话或忘记细节的听众，什么是超越性思维？是的。所以我们称之为超越性思维，因为我们有一种天生的倾向，开始对我们所见的事物赋予更深层的意义，试图理解和应对为什么、怎么会、还有什么其他可能。它的历史是什么？它背后的故事是什么？
What are the hidden intentions? What are the beliefs? What are the values that motivate this? How does it connect to the identities that those in the situation bring? How does it foretell possible different kinds of futures as we play it out over time? So that ability to sort of move beyond the immediate current details of the things you can directly discern and witness and infer from a situation and to grapple with how those
隐藏的意图是什么？动机是什么？价值观是什么？它如何与身处其中的人们所带来的身份联系起来？当我们随着时间的推移展开它时，它如何预示可能出现的不同未来？所以那种超越你所能直接辨别、见证和推断的事物的即时当前细节，并努力应对这些细节如何
connect to bigger ideas and powerful values and beliefs and stories and concepts, that's what we're calling transcendent thinking. Hmm. You know, I want to go back to Rashid's question a second ago about learning to swim, and I think I empathize
与更大的思想、强大的价值观、信仰、故事和概念联系起来的能力，这就是我们所说的超越性思维。嗯。你知道，我想回到刚才拉希德关于学习游泳的问题，我想我同情
with Rashid because I didn't learn to swim until I was an adult myself. But I have become something of a student of swimming in recent years. And when I think about swimming now, I'm thinking about, you know, hydrodynamics, I'm thinking about balance, I'm thinking about friction, I'm thinking of all the ways in which we propel ourselves through the water, but I'm also thinking about all the ways in which people have unequal access to swimming facilities,
拉希德，因为我自己直到成年才学会游泳。但近年来，我已成为一名游泳的学生。当我想到游泳时，我想到的是，你知道，流体力学，我想到的是平衡，我想到的是摩擦力，我想到的是我们穿过水面的所有方式，但我也想到人们获得游泳设施的不平等机会，
unequal access to coaching and learning, and how that manifests itself, and then who learns to swim and who does not? And in some ways, would all of these be examples of transcendent thinking, which is you have the activity itself, but the activity then becomes a springboard into thinking about these bigger questions? Absolutely. I think that's a beautiful example, right? And then swimming and the ways in which it's enabled people to engage in particular kinds of sports or particular kinds of historical activities over time and all of that that
获得教练和学习的不平等机会，以及这如何表现出来，然后是谁学会了游泳，谁没有？在某种程度上，这些都是超越性思维的例子吗，即你拥有活动本身，但活动随后成为思考这些更大问题的跳板？绝对是。我认为这是一个很好的例子，对吧？然后是游泳，以及它随着时间的推移使人们能够参与特定类型的运动或特定类型的历史活动的方式，以及所有这些
you now as a mature adult thinker bring to this one concrete activity, that is your capacity to think transcendently about concrete action-oriented goals. So in your example, Shankar, you've learned to swim, but you've also understood the act of learning to swim in this much broader way that connects to other people and to broader issues of sociality and societal access, that's the highlight of a really thoughtful way of learning about something. How do we support young people and engaging in that kind of thinking routinely in school? You say that one of the major changes we need to make in education is that rather than focus first on the material, we should focus first on the development of
你现在作为一个成熟的成年思想家带给这个具体活动的东西，这就是你对具体的、以行动为导向的目标进行超越性思考的能力。所以在你的例子中，尚卡尔，你学会了游泳，但你也以这种更广泛的方式理解了学习游泳的行为，它与其他人以及更广泛的社会性和社会准入问题联系在一起，这是真正深思熟虑的学习方式的亮点。我们如何支持年轻人经常在学校里进行那种思考？你说我们需要在教育中做出的重大改变之一是，与其首先关注材料，不如首先关注
each student. Why is that philosophical reframe important? I think what we're learning is that the ability to grow yourself and to learn in meaningful ways goes far beyond just simply, you know, storing away, stashing away in your brain like a file door, little pieces of information that you then retrieve on cue, that the most important sort of central aspect of the learning process that enables you to have information, to recall that information and to utilize it advantageously, effective. in the world moving forward, comes through the connection of this information into our subjective experience of being in the space as a learner and feeling the opportunity to learn. The emotional thought processes that we engage in as we think our way through learning opportunities become the kind of hat stand on which all the information is hooked. And so to get back into that information, you re-experience the whole of the end. enterprise. And it really points us to a new view of what's central and what the starting point is
每个学生的发展。为什么这种哲学上的重构很重要？我认为我们正在学习的是，成长自己和以有意义的方式学习的能力远远超出了仅仅，你知道，像文件柜一样存储、隐藏在你的大脑中，当你需要时检索的小块信息，学习过程中最重要的一种核心方面，使你能够拥有信息、回忆该信息并有利地利用它，有效地在未来世界中前进，来自于将这些信息与我们作为学习者身处空间并感受到学习机会的主观体验联系起来。当我们思考学习机会时所参与的情感思维过程，成为了挂载所有信息的衣帽架。因此，为了回到那些信息中，你重新体验了整个企业。它确实向我们指出了一个关于什么是核心、什么是起点的新观点
in education. Rather than thinking about how do I get this person to this endpoint, you think, who is this person? How can I facilitate them experiencing this opportunity to think about this new content in a way that they will grow themselves into someone for whom this content is part of who they are and how they understand the world? In our last conversation, Mary Helen, you cited the astonishing example of a teacher who was trying to communicate some math concepts to her students. But rather than simply communicate the math concepts, she helped them see how these math concepts apply to people who lived in their community. Can you tell me that story one more time? Yeah, I'd be happy to.
在教育中。与其考虑我如何让这个人达到这个终点，不如考虑，这个人是谁？我如何能促进他们体验这个机会，以一种他们会将自己成长为这样一个人——对他们来说，这些内容是他们是谁以及他们如何理解世界的一部分——的方式来思考这些新内容？在我们上次的对话中，玛丽·海伦，你引用了一个老师试图向学生传达一些数学概念的惊人例子。但她没有简单地传达数学概念，而是帮助他们看到了这些数学概念如何应用于生活在他们社区的人们。你能再讲一遍那个故事吗？是的，我很乐意。
So this amazing teacher, Talania Norfar, had been working with her algebra two class on exponential growth and quadratic equations. And she knew that in order to make the learning really relevant for the kids and to make them deeply committed to learning it and deeply engaged with the process of understanding how it applies and what it's for,
所以这位了不起的老师，塔拉尼亚·诺法尔，一直在和她的代数二班一起研究指数增长和二次方程。她知道，为了让学习对孩子们真正相关，并让他们深深致力于学习它，并深入参与理解它如何应用以及它是为了什么的过程，
that to build that lesson into some kind of civic opportunity to help in the community is deeply motivating to kids. It both helps them to learn the math and helps them situate the math in a broader life skill and learning opportunity to develop themselves socially, too. And so what she did in her lesson, which is brilliant, is she taught the kids, you know, how to calculate quadratic equations, how to use exponential growth. And then they applied it in a project where they became financial advisors to families from their communities who, you know, were struggling to figure out how do I pay for my children's college, how might I purchase a home someday, how do I organize my finances and think about how I should
将那节课建立成某种帮助社区的公民机会对孩子们来说是深具激励作用的。它既帮助他们学习数学，又帮助他们将数学置于更广泛的生活技能和学习机会中，以发展他们自己的社交能力。所以她在课上所做的事情，非常出色，她教孩子们，你知道，如何计算二次方程，如何使用指数增长。然后他们在一个项目中应用了它，他们成为了来自他们社区的家庭的财务顾问，这些家庭，你知道，正在努力弄清楚我如何支付孩子们的大学费用，我将来如何购买房屋，我如何组织我的财务并思考我应该如何
plan. And so the kids actually worked between the technical knowledge of the classroom and the more layperson applied ways of explaining things to families in their communities and then helped their family to figure out how to plan for the future that they wanted. And when you watch the young people, her students, in this activity, it's just amazing to see the serious demeanor, the engagement, the deep focus they bring to their math because they know this math is a useful, important way for me to help contribute to my community. And it's really important that I do it right and that I'm actually putting in in a way that will move other people's lives in a positive direction.
计划。所以孩子们实际上在课堂的技术知识和向社区家庭解释事情的更通俗的应用方式之间工作，然后帮助他们的家庭弄清楚如何为他们想要的未来做计划。当你观察年轻人，她的学生，在这个活动中时，看到他们严肃的举止、参与度、他们带给数学的深度专注真是太神奇了，因为他们知道这些数学是我帮助为我的社区做出贡献的一种有用、重要的方式。而且我做得对，并且我实际上以一种将推动其他人的生活朝着积极方向发展的方式投入其中，这非常重要。
Just that inner sense of satisfaction that comes from deeply engaging in a job well done that really changed you as a person that helped you deeply learn in a way that makes you understand your own role differently in the world and integrates, in this case, mathematical thinking into that role. That's enough. That is what kids live for. It's what we all live for. The word transcendence makes me think of concept.
仅仅是那种来自深入参与一项出色工作而产生的内在满足感，真正改变了你作为一个人的身份，帮助你以一种让你以不同方式理解自己在世界中的角色并整合——在这种情况下，将数学思维整合到该角色中——的方式深入学习。这就足够了。这就是孩子们为之生活的东西。这是我们所有人为之生活的东西。超越这个词让我想起概念。
like awe, the feeling we get when we see a shooting star or visit a place like the Grand Canyon. We've talked in the past on the show about feelings of awe and why they might be beneficial to us. We received a question that's somewhat related from a teacher named Rose. Here she is. I'm just wondering, after listening to your podcast on how our brains learn, if there's any more that could also be said about the impact of things that are beautiful or you seem to like start to talk about the concept of wonder and how that relates to a student's learning
比如敬畏，当我们看到流星或参观像大峡谷这样的地方时产生的感觉。我们过去在节目中谈论过敬畏感以及它们为什么可能对我们有益。我们收到了一位名叫罗斯的老师提出的一个相关问题。她在这里。我只是想知道，在听了你们关于我们的大脑如何学习的播客后，关于美丽事物的影响，或者你似乎开始谈论惊奇的概念以及它如何与学生的学习相关，是否还有更多可以说的
and desire to learn more and to have specific interests. But I'm also just interested in how it kind of touches on other things too. And in particular, I'm just very interested in the concept of letting students hear beautiful music or see beautiful things or create beautiful projects and what that does to a student's learning and progress. How is the concept of transcendent thinking connected to beauty and feelings of awe, Mary Helen? I think this is just an amazing connection you make, Rose, because if you try to think about what is it that actually enables us as human beings to appreciate beauty, to experience an emotion
以及学习更多的愿望和拥有特定的兴趣。但我也只是对它如何触及其他事物感兴趣。特别是，我非常对让学生听到美丽的音乐或看到美丽的事物或创造美丽的项目的概念感兴趣，以及这对学生的学习和进步有什么影响。超越性思维的概念与美和敬畏感是如何联系在一起的，玛丽·海伦？我认为这是一个非常了不起的联系，罗斯，因为如果你试图思考是什么真正使我们作为人类能够欣赏美，体验一种
like awe, to wonder? What we're really saying is we are looking for the deeper, bigger meaning, the emotional reason why things happen the way they do or could happen. And that taps into a fundamental connection that we found in our work between transcendent thinking. and emotion. Samir Zeki, for example, at University College London, has a beautiful study from some years ago with mathematicians in which they showed mathematicians equations that are quote-unquote beautiful and equations that are quote-unquote awkward or ugly. And just the fact that experts in math knew what you mean by this already tells you what it actually means to be an expert in math. To be an expert means I can see an equation.
像敬畏、惊奇这样的情感？我们真正要说的是，我们正在寻找更深、更大的意义，即事物以这种方式发生或可能发生的内在情感原因。这触及了我们在工作中发现的超越性思维与情感之间的一种基本联系。例如，伦敦大学学院的萨米尔·泽基几年前对数学家进行了一项美丽的研究，其中他们向数学家展示了所谓的“美丽”方程和所谓的“笨拙”或“丑陋”方程。仅仅是数学专家知道你所说的意思这一事实，就已经告诉了你成为数学专家实际上意味着什么。成为专家意味着我可以看到一个方程，
and imagine in my mind all the powerful ways it could be used to explain phenomena in the world that matter. That ability to extrapolate and apply in many contexts is the essence of transcendence again. So yes, transcendence can apply to things that are aesthetic and beautiful, but the wonderful thing is that the act of being able to begin to grapple transcendently with concepts can help us to imbue those concepts with beauty, even when those concepts are things that people who are not experts may not think of as, quote-unquote, beautiful, like a math equation. Feeling excitement and awe while learning something new is a wonderful experience. But is it possible to consistently cultivate transcendent thinking in our educational systems?
并在我的脑海中想象它可能被用来解释世界上重要的现象的所有强大方式。那种在许多环境中推断和应用的能力再次是超越的本质。所以是的，超越可以应用于审美和美丽的事物，但美妙之处在于，能够开始超越性地处理概念的行为可以帮助我们赋予这些概念以美，即使这些概念是那些非专家可能不会认为“美丽”的事物，比如数学方程。在学习新事物时感到兴奋和敬畏是一种美妙的体验。但是，是否有可能在我们的教育系统中持续培养超越性思维？
When we come back, the teacher's perspective. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. Picture in your mind the best teacher you ever had. What was it that made this person memorable? Did they make you excited about ideas you hadn't cared about? Did they help you overcome a hurdle in learning how to read
当我们回来时，老师的视角。你正在收听《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。在你的脑海中想象你曾经拥有的最好的老师。是什么让这个人令人难忘？他们是否让你对你以前不关心的想法感到兴奋？他们是否帮助你克服了学习阅读的障碍
or explain a math concept in a way that made it understandable? Did they spot a learning disability that no one else had noticed or see how problems at home were affecting your ability to concentrate? Great teachers profoundly shaped the trajectory of their students' lives, But the pressure and expectations we put on teachers, to inspire, to nurture, to master complex curricular requirements, to serve as de facto social workers, it can all be overwhelming. We heard from a number of teachers living this reality in response to our earlier conversation with Mary Helen Imordino-Yang.
或者以一种使其易于理解的方式解释数学概念？他们是否发现了其他人没有注意到的学习障碍，或者看到了家里的问题如何影响你的专注能力？伟大的老师深刻地塑造了学生的生活轨迹，但我们施加给老师的压力和期望，去激励、去培养、去掌握复杂的课程要求、去充当事实上的社会工作者，这一切都可能让人不知所措。在回应我们之前与玛丽·海伦·伊莫迪诺-杨的对话时，我们听到了许多生活在这种现实中的老师的声音。
She's a psychologist and neuroscientist at the University of Southern California, an author of Emotions, Learning, and the Brain, exploring the education. educational implications of affective neuroscience. Mary Helen, I'd like to focus in this segment on the perspective of teachers. We received an email from a teacher named Eileen, who writes, We are at the mercy of unrealistic pacing guides, scripted curriculums, state standards in every subject that allow for little deviation for students to pursue individual interests, unrealistic demands on teachers to cover too many content areas,
她是南加州大学的心理学家和神经科学家，《情感、学习与大脑》的作者，探索情感神经科学的教育意义。玛丽·海伦，我想在这一部分关注老师的视角。我们收到了一封名叫艾琳的老师的电子邮件，她写道，我们受制于不切实际的进度指南、脚本化的课程、每个学科的国家标准，这些标准几乎不允许学生追求个人兴趣，对老师覆盖太多内容领域的不切实际的要求，
and the meteoric rise in chronic absenteeism. Does your guest have any meaningful, realistic solutions for implementing the ideas in these contexts? Engagement is key, along with building relationships with children and their families, but it isn't enough to solve education's problems. I suggest your guest advocate at a state and national level for the overhaul of pre-K through 12th grade education
以及慢性缺勤的急剧上升。你的嘉宾对在这些环境中实施这些想法有什么有意义、现实的解决方案吗？参与是关键，同时还要与孩子及其家庭建立关系，但这不足以解决教育的问题。我建议你的嘉宾在州和国家层面倡导对学前班到12年级的教育进行彻底改革。
instead of putting the onus solely on teachers. The message rarely gets from professors or neuroscientists in the ivory tower to the woefully uninformed politicians who are making decisions about curriculum. Teachers, unfortunately, are not calling the shots about curriculum. So Mary Helen, I think I can hear both Eileen's critique, but also the place of hurt and frustration that this is coming from.
而不是仅仅把责任推给老师。这些信息很少能从象牙塔里的教授或神经科学家那里传达到那些对情况一无所知、却在制定课程决策的政客耳中。遗憾的是，老师们并没有课程的决定权。所以玛丽·海伦，我想我既能听出艾琳的批评，也能感受到这番话背后所蕴含的伤痛与挫折感。
How would you respond to her? Oh, Eileen, you are absolutely 100% right. And we are working very hard ourselves at USC, and many of my colleagues to overhaul the education system. So what we've done to design schools to improve outcomes and achievement levels, which by the way are also at historic lows, is to buckle down on basics, to narrow things, to script things to standardize. And at one level that could make sense, unfortunately, it is completely contrary to the ways that human beings actually grow and learn. We grow and learn through the active experiencing, the subjective emotional experiencing
你会如何回应她呢？哦，艾琳，你绝对是百分之百正确的。我们自己在南加州大学，以及我的许多同事，都在非常努力地重构教育体系。我们为了改善学校设计以提高成果和成就水平——顺便提一下，这些水平目前也处于历史低点——所做的事情，就是死抠基础、缩减内容、将教学脚本化和标准化。在某种层面上这似乎说得通，但遗憾的是，这完全违背了人类实际成长和学习的方式。我们通过主动的体验，即主观的情感体验来成长和学习
of content. This leaves teachers like yourself, Eileen, in a really difficult place because you know what your children need is not what you are required to give them. What we really need to do is step back and for teachers remind yourselves that ultimately the children are under your care and the care of your principals and administrators. And we need to protect our teachers and our administrators who are working on behalf of children by helping them to have the autonomy they need to build into their curricula the kinds of structures
内容。这让像你这样的老师，艾琳，处于一个非常困难的境地，因为你知道孩子们需要的并不是你被要求提供给他们的东西。我们真正需要做的是退后一步，提醒老师们，归根结底，孩子们是在你们以及你们的校长和行政人员的照管之下。我们需要保护那些为孩子工作的老师和行政人员，帮助他们获得所需的自主权，以便将各种结构融入到他们的课程中
that will enable young people to thrive as best as we can while also working to change the system. But what we can do to the best of our ability is to mitigate their harms by interpreting them in a way for young people and for our practice that puts them in a less prominent place in the classroom context so that kids and families understand that they can exhale, they can settle in, they can start to engage with ideas that are in that curriculum, they are in that standardized curriculum, and they can start to build out ways to work
这将使年轻人尽可能地茁壮成长，同时我们也致力于改变这个体系。但我们能做的最好的事情，就是通过为年轻人和我们的实践解读这些体系，来减轻它们的危害，使它们在课堂环境中处于不那么突出的位置，这样孩子们和家庭就能明白，他们可以放松下来，可以安定下来，可以开始接触课程中的那些思想，那些标准化的课程，并开始建立起应对和处理这些内容的方法。
and move through it. But I am 100% with you, Eileen. We really need to read the think, the norms and the aims of our education system in light of the developmental needs of our young people. And let me be very clear, this is not code speak for lowering standards or making less content available to kids. This means we teach and we learn in a fundamentally different orientation. We start with the human being at the center, their experience of the process, and we think not about the learning as the outcome, but the learning as the the means, the outcome as the human development. A teacher named Charles called in with a concern about how to realistically implement
但我百分之百支持你，艾琳。我们确实需要根据年轻人的发展需求，重新审视我们教育体系的思维、规范和目标。让我说清楚，这并不是降低标准或减少提供给孩子的内容的代名词。这意味着我们以一种根本不同的导向进行教学和学习。我们以人为本，关注他们对过程的体验，我们思考的不是将学习作为结果，而是将学习作为手段，将人类的发展作为结果。一位名叫查尔斯的老师打来电话，表达了他对如何切实地大规模实施
transcendent thinking at scale. Hi. I've been a teacher for over 25 years during this time. I've worked really hard to create classroom environments very much like the ones described in the episode. The issue has always been scalability. I've been told countless times that the way that I do things is, you know, unique to me. In fact, I just stepped out of the classroom for the first time in over 25 years
超越性思维的担忧。你好。我当老师已经超过25年了。在这段时间里，我非常努力地创造了非常类似于本期节目中所描述的那种课堂环境。问题一直在于可扩展性。我无数次被告知，我做事的方式是，你知道的，是我独有的。事实上，我刚刚在25年多来第一次离开了教室
to start a nonprofit to try to dispel that issue. And ironically, as I've left the classroom, the courses that I've created that have given students more real-world experience, more autonomy in their learning, are gone. The school was unable to sustain them without my presence, despite my many attempts over the years to create an environment which other teachers learned and became involved. And the materials that I used in the class were well developed and organized, and I had offered support. So my question, I guess, is around scalability. How scalable are these ideas in classrooms to create environments I think are so desperately needed for students? So Mary Helen, Charles is clearly on the same page as you in many ways,
去创办一家非营利组织，试图消除这个问题。讽刺的是，当我离开教室后，我所创造的那些让学生有更多现实世界经验、在学习中有更多自主权的课程，也随之消失了。学校在我不在的情况下无法维持这些课程，尽管我多年来多次尝试创造一个让其他老师学习并参与进来的环境。而且我在课堂上使用的材料开发得很好，组织得也很严密，我也提供了支持。所以我想我的问题是关于可扩展性的。这些想法在课堂上创造出我认为学生们迫切需要的环境，其可扩展性如何？所以玛丽·海伦，查尔斯显然在很多方面与你想法一致，
but is asking, I think, a practical question. Does this simply rely on the individual brilliant teacher, or can this be scaled? Well, Charles, thank you for your service to kids and for your hard work now in a nonprofit. And sadly, your story is not a unique one. I hear this kind of story a lot where there's one unique sort of unicorn teacher who has designed all these amazing experiences for kids. And as soon as they step away from it, others can't sustain it and it peters out, and or they are told, this can't scale. This is something special and unique.
但他问的是一个实际的问题。这是否仅仅依赖于个别杰出的老师，还是可以推广？嗯，查尔斯，感谢你为孩子们所做的贡献，以及你现在在非营利组织所做的努力。遗憾的是，你的故事并非个例。我经常听到这样的故事，有一个独特的“独角兽”老师为孩子们设计了所有这些奇妙的体验。而一旦他们离开，其他人就无法维持，它就逐渐消失了，或者他们被告知，这无法推广。这是某种特殊且独特的东西。
What we really need to do is go back and change the ways in which we train and support our teachers, and then the ways in which we assess our young people in our classrooms. You can't scale what you don't understand. And the ultimate problem, I think, and the reason maybe why your amazing lessons were lost after you moved to a different career line is that your colleagues around you could appreciate the amazing things you were doing, but they didn't actually have the skill to understand why and how you developed it that way. What we really need to do is help teachers to understand that the nature of their work is to be like scientists in the class. developmental scientists. You move through your class as an observer. You're inquiring, you're wondering, you're trying to figure out how are young people thinking and feeling here? How are they understanding things? How are they experiencing the learning process? And how might I, given what I'm witnessing, working together with them, build out inviting opportunities
我们真正需要做的是回头改变我们培训和支持老师的方式，以及我们在课堂上评估年轻人的方式。你无法推广你不理解的东西。我认为根本问题，以及为什么你的精彩课程在你转行后就丢失了的原因，可能是你周围的同事虽然能欣赏你所做的精彩事情，但他们实际上并没有能力理解你为什么以及如何以那种方式开发它。我们真正需要做的是帮助老师理解，他们工作的本质就像班级里的科学家。发展科学家。你作为观察者在课堂中穿行。你在探究，你在好奇，你在试图弄清楚年轻人在想什么、感受什么？他们是如何理解事物的？他们是如何体验学习过程的？鉴于我所见证的，我如何能与他们合作，建立起引人入胜的机会
for them to experience things in a way that both promotes high, level thinking and learning, and enables them to own it in the way your lessons had. There's been a lot of discussion in the past few years about screens, particularly cell phones, and how they affect children's ability to focus and learn. Another technology that's also generated a lot of concern among educators over the last couple of years is artificial intelligence. Here's listener Sangita with a question on that front. For over 13 years, I've worked in the nonprofit sector developing parent education programs and supporting families and children. Over this time, I've seen firsthand how the rapidly evolving digital and now AI-driven landscape is reshaping childhood,
让他们以一种既能促进高水平思维和学习，又能让他们像你的课程那样拥有学习成果的方式去体验事物。过去几年里，关于屏幕，特别是手机，以及它们如何影响儿童专注和学习能力，有很多讨论。过去几年里，另一种也引起教育工作者极大关注的技术是人工智能。这是听众桑吉塔提出的相关问题。13年多来，我一直在非营利部门工作，开发家长教育项目并支持家庭和儿童。在这段时间里，我亲眼目睹了快速发展的数字环境，以及现在以人工智能驱动的环境，是如何重塑童年、
adolescence, and parenting. Many parents, particularly those from vulnerable backgrounds, feel overwhelmed and underprepared to guide their children through these changes. I was therefore hoping to ask Dr. Imordino-Yang that as AI continues to try to try and transform education, much of the research and innovation focuses on supporting teachers and schools. But parents, especially those from low-income, low-literacy or migrant backgrounds, are often left behind. What advice or insights would she offer to educators like me who are working to bridge this gap and help parents better support their children in an AI-driven world? What do you think, Mary Helen?
青春期和育儿方式的。许多家长，特别是那些来自弱势背景的家长，感到不知所措，且没有准备好引导孩子应对这些变化。因此，我希望能问问伊莫迪诺-杨博士，随着人工智能继续试图改变教育，大部分研究和创新都集中在支持老师和学校上。但家长们，尤其是那些来自低收入、低识字率或移民背景的家长，往往被遗忘。对于像我这样致力于弥合这一差距，帮助家长在人工智能驱动的世界中更好地支持孩子的教育工作者，她会提供什么建议或见解？你觉得呢，玛丽·海伦？
How does transcendent thinking intersect with the world of artificial intelligence? Well, again, Sangita, I'll say you are not the first person to notice this, and you are absolutely right to say this. I think there are many people who are concerned about it, and there's also, like you say, a huge push toward bringing AI into the classroom, and the main work in that direction has been on how to help teachers learn how to leverage these technologies effectively. That's important, but what is even more important and even more pressing, which is, I think, the essence of your question, is how are these opportunities shaping the way our young people think and feel, conceptualize a sense of self, build engagement and motivation? What does it mean to think with these technological mediators as compared to in ways that we did without these mediators? And how might that be changing the nature of our development as human beings? We don't know the to those questions. But here's what I would say in terms of the second half of your question, which is how should you support the parents and families and children that you're working with. I think you need to trust and help parents trust that they know what it means to be a human being.
超越性思维如何与人工智能世界相交织？嗯，同样，桑吉塔，我会说你不是第一个注意到这一点的人，你说得完全正确。我认为有很多人对此感到担忧，而且正如你所说，将人工智能引入课堂的呼声也非常高，而这一方向的主要工作一直是如何帮助老师学习如何有效地利用这些技术。这很重要，但更重要、更紧迫的是——我认为这是你问题的核心——这些机会是如何塑造我们年轻人思考和感受、概念化自我意识、建立参与感和动力的方式的？与我们没有这些中介时相比，带着这些技术中介去思考意味着什么？这可能会如何改变我们作为人类的发展本质？我们不知道这些问题的答案。但关于你问题的后半部分，即你应该如何支持你所服务的家长、家庭和孩子，我会说：我认为你需要信任并帮助家长相信，他们知道作为一个人意味着什么。
And they know how to love and care for their children. They need in this space more than ever to stay deeply connected with their children and with their children's ways of thinking and engaging with their schoolwork and to reflect with those kids about the experiences they have in thinking through these things, to work with them on their work, to notice what kinds of changes
他们知道如何去爱和关心他们的孩子。在这个空间里，他们比以往任何时候都更需要与孩子保持深度联系，了解孩子思考和参与学校作业的方式，并与孩子们一起反思他们在思考这些事情时的经历，与他们一起完成作业，注意孩子们在参与这些技术时发生了什么样的变化，
are happening in their kids as they're engaging in these technologies and think about what do we want for our children, which kinds of uses are appropriate and effective and are making us more efficient, and which kinds may be interfering with aspects of the learning or developmental process that kids want and need to grapple with in order to really build for themselves the experience of being an efficacious, agentic learner.
并思考我们想要给孩子什么，哪些使用方式是适当且有效的，能让我们更高效，而哪些方式可能会干扰孩子们想要和需要去应对的学习或发展过程，以便真正为自己建立起成为一个高效、有主见的学习者的体验。
And when we are concretizing and reducing the aims of our educational experiences in school to the output of particular kinds of skills that may be, quote, unquote, relevant to the world today, oftentimes what we're forgetting is how does the learning of that skills, change the development of the person, and those are the questions we need to be asking ourselves. The example I used to explain this is that giving kids AI to learn to do something basic that they before would have needed to know, but now AI can do it, so why bother teaching them? It's kind of the same thing as telling parents of eight-month-olds, oh, don't bother encouraging your child to crawl. You're never going to use that skill again. Who crawls? Unless you lose something under the couch, you're never going to need to do this, right? just get right up on a bicycle, start riding, start running, right? Of course, infants don't crawl
当我们把学校教育体验的目标具体化并简化为某种可能与当今世界“相关”的特定技能产出时，我们往往忘记了学习这些技能是如何改变一个人的发展的，而这些正是我们需要问自己的问题。我用来解释这个例子的方法是：给孩子们人工智能去学习做一些他们以前需要知道的基础事情，但现在人工智能可以做了，那为什么还要费心教他们呢？这有点像告诉八个月大孩子的家长，哦，别费心鼓励你的孩子爬行了。你以后再也不会用到那个技能了。谁会爬行呢？除非你把东西掉在沙发底下，否则你永远不需要做这个，对吧？直接站起来骑自行车，开始骑行，开始奔跑，对吧？当然，婴儿不爬行
because crawling is a useful life skill forever. They crawl because the act of crawling enables certain kind of positionality in the world, which helps them to develop themselves neurologically, psychologically over time. And crawling is engaging networks for motion, for thinking, for reflection, for planning, for movement that then become the basis for healthy kinds of behavior that don't involve crawling later. We need really to return to that logic when we're asking ourselves what we want for our children. We need, again, to put on those scientific hats, those thoughtful hats. We need to engage with our young people and think about how are they using the technology? How are they experiencing this? Are they engaging with the big
并不是因为爬行是一项终身有用的生活技能。他们爬行是因为爬行的动作使他们在世界上能够实现某种定位，这有助于他们随着时间的推移在神经学和心理学上发展自己。爬行是在调动运动、思考、反思、规划和移动的网络，这些网络随后成为后来不需要爬行的健康行为的基础。当我们问自己想要给孩子什么时，我们确实需要回归到那种逻辑。我们需要再次戴上那些科学的帽子，那些深思熟虑的帽子。我们需要与我们的年轻人互动，思考他们是如何使用技术的？他们是如何体验这一点的？他们是否在参与我希望他们参与的宏大
ideas I want them to engage with? But they're doing it in a different format that I'm not used to because I wasn't an AI native the way they are? Or are they actually circumventing developmental processes that we value for them. And is that leading to certain kinds of holes or differences in their development, which are problematic? And I would argue that instances of both are existing in our use of AI right now. And we need really to get to the bottom of how we want our young children to develop in today's world. And that should be the driving North Star toward which we point our designs that are going to leverage AI. And in some ways, this speaks to what you said at the start of our conversation, which is you're focusing on the person and not on the learning.
思想？但他们是以一种我所不习惯的、不同的格式在做这件事，因为我不是像他们那样的“人工智能原住民”？还是他们实际上在规避我们为他们所珍视的发展过程？这是否导致了他们发展中某些方面的缺失或差异，而这些是成问题的？我认为目前我们对人工智能的使用中，这两种情况都存在。我们确实需要彻底弄清楚我们希望我们的幼儿在当今世界中如何发展。这应该成为我们指向那些将利用人工智能的设计的指路明灯。在某种程度上，这呼应了我们在谈话开始时所说的，即你关注的是人，而不是学习。
So I think right now, many educators and parents are worried if my kid basically turns in an essay instead of actually writing the essay himself, perhaps he's not learning how to write the essay. And that's true. But what you're saying is actually the deeper point. What does it mean that this person hasn't learned this developmental scale? Is it possible? This is a step that we could just skip over and go past, in which case it's fine? or what if this turns out to be an essential step in something that is really important to this person
所以我认为现在，许多教育工作者和家长担心，如果我的孩子基本上是交上一篇论文，而不是自己真正写那篇论文，也许他并没有学会如何写论文。这是事实。但你所说的是更深层次的观点。这个人没有学到这种发展技能意味着什么？这是否可能是一个我们可以跳过并继续前进的步骤，如果是这样，那没关系？或者如果这被证明是这个人未来
two years, five years, 20 years down the road? That's exactly right. So we really need to think back and look and say, what is the goal of this learning exercise, actually? Is it to move your pencil on the paper? Sometimes it actually may be when you're five or you're six years old, right?
两年、五年、二十年后非常重要的事情中必不可少的一步呢？完全正确。所以我们确实需要回过头来看看，问问自己：这个学习练习的目标到底是什么？是为了在纸上移动你的铅笔吗？有时候当你五岁或六岁时，这确实可能是目标，对吧？
And that you're actually learning motor skill and planning skill by learning to handwriting. It doesn't matter if you can type later. The act of learning to move your hand in these planful ways, turns out to have important developmental affordances for the brain. Or is this a skill that we really don't need anymore, that modern society can skip over because it's something that doesn't seem to actually develop dispositions or propensities of mind that are going to be useful later, and we can drop it and let it go.
而且你实际上是通过学习手写来学习运动技能和规划技能。以后会不会打字并不重要。学习以这些有计划的方式移动你的手，被证明对大脑具有重要的发展启示。或者这是否是一项我们确实不再需要的技能，现代社会可以跳过它，因为它似乎并没有真正发展出以后会有用的思维倾向或习性，我们可以放弃它，让它过去。
When we come back, Mary Helen and Mordino-Yang answers questions from parents, And we consider how the ideas we're talking about today apply not just to young people in classrooms, but to everyone. You're listening to Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. This is Hidden Brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. University of Southern California, Mary Helen Imordino-Yang researches how we teach our children and what really works to help them become critical thinkers and creative problem solvers. Mary Helen joins us today for our latest installment of your questions answered, featuring listeners' questions about her research.
回来后，玛丽·海伦和伊莫迪诺-杨将回答家长们的问题，我们将探讨今天讨论的想法不仅适用于课堂上的年轻人，也适用于每个人。你正在收听的是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。这是《隐藏的大脑》。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。南加州大学的玛丽·海伦·伊莫迪诺-杨研究我们如何教育孩子，以及什么真正有助于帮助他们成为批判性思考者和创造性的问题解决者。玛丽·海伦今天加入我们，参加我们最新的“回答你的问题”环节，回答听众关于她研究的问题。
So Mary Helen, we heard from many parents who saw connections between your ideas and other well-known pedagogical approaches. Here's Chris. I really enjoyed this episode because what she said, to me, felt very intuitive and obvious. My question is, what she described sounds a lot like the Montessori system. So how is what she's describing different or is it different at all? Thank you. So the Montessori method is a self-directed approach where students decide where their interests lie and pursue learning around those interests. How do your findings compare with that idea, Mary Helen. Yes, well, Chris, you're absolutely right that these ideas that I'm bringing
所以玛丽·海伦，我们从许多家长那里听到，他们看到了你的想法与其他著名教学方法之间的联系。这是克里斯。我真的很喜欢这一期节目，因为她所说的，对我来说，感觉非常直观和显而易见。我的问题是，她所描述的听起来很像蒙台梭利系统。那么她所描述的与蒙台梭利有什么不同，或者根本没有区别？谢谢。所以蒙台梭利教学法是一种自我导向的方法，学生决定他们的兴趣所在，并围绕这些兴趣追求学习。你的研究结果与那个想法相比如何，玛丽·海伦。是的，嗯，克里斯，你说得完全正确，我所提出的这些想法
forth now echo and build from and incorporate many kinds of pedagogical approaches that have been developed over ages. And so, whereas I won't speak to any specific educational approach like Montessori versus others, these approaches vary in that they are focusing young people on the opportunities to make choices and to agentically move through the learning opportunity. The ways in which those learning opportunities are set up will have very important implications for the ways in which young people learn. For example, together with a young scientist named Solange de Nouveau, who is in Geneva, Switzerland, we did some studies of the effect of Montessori classroom experience versus traditional classroom experience. And we wanted to understand whether
现在呼应、建立并融合了多年来发展起来的多种教学方法。因此，虽然我不会谈论任何特定的教育方法，如蒙台梭利与其他方法相比，这些方法的不同之处在于，它们让年轻人有机会做出选择，并能动地通过学习机会前进。这些学习机会的设置方式将对年轻人学习的方式产生非常重要的影响。例如，我们与日内瓦的一位名叫索兰奇·德·努沃的年轻科学家一起，对蒙台梭利课堂体验与传统课堂体验的效果进行了一些研究。我们想了解
those experiences of learning the math would actually shape the way the kids processed math in real-time in an MRI scanner. So what we did, Solange had eight to 12-year-old math students from Montessori schools and traditional schools in Geneva, come to her lab and solve math problems in the scanner, among other things, while we were scanning their brain. And the first thing that we found was that the Montessori schooled kids in this context and the traditionally schooled kids got the same number of math problems right. That's wonderful because that means now both groups of kids are learning a lot of math content and can solve problems. Fantastic. You could stop there and traditional education would stop there saying, okay, so both school systems are
那些学习数学的体验是否真的会塑造孩子们在核磁共振扫描仪中实时处理数学的方式。所以我们所做的是，索兰奇让来自日内瓦蒙台梭利学校和传统学校的8到12岁的数学学生来到她的实验室，在扫描仪中解决数学问题，以及其他事情，同时我们扫描他们的大脑。我们发现的第一件事是，在这种背景下，蒙台梭利学校的孩子和传统学校的孩子做对的数学题数量相同。这太棒了，因为这意味着现在两组孩子都在学习大量的数学内容，并且能够解决问题。太棒了。你可以在这里停下来，传统教育会在这里停下来，说，好吧，所以两种学校系统在
effective at teaching kids math, we're done. But you would be missing something very important and I suspect that this is what Chris was getting at. When we looked again, we could see that whereas the two groups of kids got the same number of problems right, the Montessori kids got far more wrong. That's because they didn't skip the things they weren't sure of. They took a whirl and just tried. And when they got it wrong, they engaged brain networks that showed that they were trying to make sense of what had happened
教孩子数学方面都是有效的，我们完成了。但你会错过一些非常重要的事情，我怀疑这正是克里斯想要表达的。当我们再次观察时，我们可以看到，虽然两组孩子做对的问题数量相同，但蒙台梭利的孩子做错的要多得多。这是因为他们没有跳过那些他们不确定的题目。他们尝试了一下，只是试了试。当他们做错时，他们调动了大脑网络，显示出他们正在试图弄清楚发生了什么，
and were actively grappling with the mathematical content. And then the next time they saw a problem like that one, they were more likely to get it right. The traditionally schooled kids, by contrast, when they saw something that they got right, their brains showed activity patterns that suggested they were trying to remember that. It's as if they were saying like, oh, that's right, quick, store that to memory, so you can do it again just the same way. When they got something wrong, we didn't see this kind of active grappling. And in turn, we saw a longer pause as if they were sort of freaking out a little bit. And then when they saw the same kind of problem again, they were not more likely to get it right.
并且正在积极地与数学内容进行博弈。然后下一次他们看到类似的问题时，他们更有可能做对。相比之下，传统学校的孩子，当他们看到他们做对的东西时，他们的大脑显示出的活动模式表明他们正在试图记住它。就好像他们在说，哦，对了，快，把它存入记忆，这样你就可以用同样的方式再做一次。当他们做错时，我们没有看到这种积极的博弈。反过来，我们看到了更长的停顿，就好像他们有点惊慌失措。然后当他们再次看到同样的问题时，他们并没有更有可能做对。
They got it wrong over and over again. When you feel like the goal of math class is to solve a problem and someone else knows the answer and I give it to them and then they tell me, that is a certain way of privileging and emoting about the process. You have emotions about correct and incorrect answers, right? In the Montessori case, kids' emotions weren't about the right and wrong answers. They actually didn't show different emotional patterns if they got it right or got it wrong. Instead, when they got things wrong, they were actually using that as an opportunity to get information and to learn something new. The act of thinking through the math problem felt like a fundamentally different process to them.
他们一次又一次地做错。当你觉得数学课的目标是解决一个问题，而别人知道答案，我把它交给他们，然后他们告诉我，这是一种对过程进行特权化和情感化的方式。你对正确和错误的答案有情绪，对吧？在蒙台梭利的情况下，孩子们的情绪并不是关于正确和错误的答案。如果他们做对了或做错了，他们实际上并没有表现出不同的情绪模式。相反，当他们做错时，他们实际上是利用这个机会来获取信息并学习新东西。思考数学问题的行为对他们来说感觉是一个根本不同的过程。
And in fact, it was, even though their quote-unquote level of math knowledge was the same. And you can see how this leads eventually not just to doing well in school or not doing well in school, but to human development writ large, because of course, once students graduate from school or college and they enter the real world and they're dealing with relationships and they're dealing with jobs and they're dealing with setbacks, what you want is people to actually embrace problems and say, oh, that's an interesting problem. I don't know how to solve it. Let me engage with it as opposed to asking, what's the right answer? What's the right answer? Did I get the right answer? Absolutely. I mean, amen to that, right? And take a look at the state of the world right now. When we move through the world, expecting that there is one correct answer and that someone somewhere knows it and that we want that answer and anyone who has a different answer or a different way of thinking about it is wrong. And when we aren't dispositionally curious to engage with many ways of understanding the complexities of situations, where does that leave us as citizens? In effect, the rethinking of school around the development of the people inside the school is exactly for what you're saying. It is to prepare young people with the dispositions of mind to solve complex, real-world problems that do not have one concrete answer, that may represent a very complex problem space that's fraught, that we need to grapple with together.
事实上，确实如此，尽管他们所谓的数学知识水平是一样的。你可以看到这最终不仅会导致在学校表现好或不好，而且会导致广泛的人类发展，因为当然，一旦学生从学校或大学毕业，进入现实世界，处理人际关系，处理工作，处理挫折，你想要的是人们真正拥抱问题并说，哦，那是一个有趣的问题。我不知道怎么解决它。让我参与其中，而不是问，正确答案是什么？正确答案是什么？我得到正确答案了吗？绝对是。我的意思是，对此表示赞同，对吧？看看现在世界的状态。当我们在这个世界上穿行，期望有一个正确的答案，并且某处有人知道它，我们想要那个答案，而任何有不同答案或不同思考方式的人都是错的。当我们没有好奇心去接触多种理解复杂情况的方式时，这让我们作为公民处于什么境地？实际上，围绕学校内部人员的发展来重新思考学校，正是为了你所说的。它是为了让年轻人具备解决复杂、现实世界问题的思维倾向，这些问题没有一个具体的答案，可能代表了一个充满矛盾的非常复杂的问题空间，我们需要共同应对。
and the most important problems that are facing humanity and the planet today are 201 of that sort. They are complex, they are fraught, there are many kinds of legitimate perspectives, there are many ways of experiencing the implications. How do we set up our young people so that they are dispositional curious to engage with that complexity and to wrestle with it together in humane, respectful ways that enable us to settle into conversations that are civically oriented, that are productive, that are pushing us in beneficial directions as a society, as a community, and as individuals. And that is essentially the ultimate purpose of school, applying all of our knowledge in those developmentally rich ways.
而当今人类和地球面临的最重要的问题正是这一类的。它们很复杂，充满矛盾，有许多合法的观点，有许多体验其影响的方式。我们如何设置我们的年轻人，使他们有好奇心去接触这种复杂性，并以人道、尊重的方式共同努力，使我们能够安定下来进行以公民为导向、富有成效、推动我们作为一个社会、社区和个人向有益方向发展的对话。这本质上是学校的最终目的，以那些富有发展意义的方式应用我们所有的知识。
We got a very interesting question from a listener named Taylor. She's 33 years old, and your research resonated with her based on where she's at in her career. Here's Taylor. So I was wondering, based on your research on student engagement in educational settings, what insights or strategies could be effectively applied to enhance employee engagement and motivation in the professional environment? Specifically, how might these findings help individuals like me who are feeling disengaged or unfulfilled in their own careers? What do you think, Mary Helen?
我们从一位名叫泰勒的听众那里得到了一个非常有趣的问题。她33岁，根据她目前的职业生涯，你的研究引起了她的共鸣。这是泰勒。所以我想知道，根据你对教育环境中学生参与度的研究，哪些见解或策略可以有效地应用于提高专业环境中的员工参与度和动力？具体来说，这些发现如何帮助像我这样在自己的职业生涯中感到脱节或未得到满足的人？你觉得呢，玛丽·海伦？
Yes, well, Taylor, there is a whole field of research. that focuses on exactly that question. But I'll quickly say here that because people in the workplace are, first and foremost, people. These same principles hold. And really effective leaders and managers manage well because they tap into the developmental capacities and potentials of the people that are working with them and enable those people to invent just in time ways, of doing things and understanding things, that feel empowering to them
是的，嗯，泰勒，有一个完整的研究领域专门关注那个问题。但我会在这里快速说一下，因为工作场所的人首先是人。这些原则同样适用。真正有效的领导者和管理者管理得好，是因为他们挖掘了与他们一起工作的人的发展能力和潜力，并使这些人能够及时发明做事和理解事物的方式，这让他们感到被赋权，
and that actually contribute to the productivity of the whole group while growing the people themselves. So I think what you're noticing, Taylor, is exactly right. We need to really be focusing on the ways in which people in their careers feel themselves growing, feel themselves interacting with others, contributing to a communal way of understanding their problem and doing their work.
并且实际上有助于整个团队的生产力，同时让人们自己成长。所以我认为你所注意到的是完全正确的。我们需要真正关注人们在职业生涯中感到自己成长、感到自己与他人互动、为理解他们的问题和完成工作做出共同贡献的方式。
And that is what is powerful. That's what makes us productive, and that's what helps us. to grow ourselves and to do our best work. I'd like to end by hearing about an interesting educational experience from a listener named Molly. I went to a very non-traditional elementary school in the mid-70s, and this school's approach was very close to what Dr. Imordino talked about.
而这就是强大的力量。这就是让我们高效的原因，也是帮助我们成长并尽我们所能做好工作的原因。我想以听众莫莉的一个有趣的教育经历作为结束。我在70年代中期上了一所非常非传统的公立小学，这所学校的方法非常接近伊莫迪诺博士所谈论的内容。
Students were encouraged to come up with their own projects and learning ideas. One time we wondered if for newly established Earth Day, we could have a celebration that would create zero trash. And so the students went about working on ways to have some kind of a celebration using totally edible tableware, et cetera. This school also traditionally outscored the other elementary schools on the standardized testing. It was a fabulous experience, and I felt like I loved going to school. When I had to transfer into junior high, I remember our teacher in a math class early in the year was giving a test to see what we knew in the math class. and it was the first time I'd sat in rows and faced forward instead of at tables where I could
学生们被鼓励提出自己的项目和学习想法。有一次我们想知道，对于新设立的地球日，我们是否可以举办一个零垃圾的庆祝活动。于是学生们开始研究如何使用完全可食用的餐具等方式来举办某种庆祝活动。这所学校在标准化考试中也传统上超过了其他小学。那是一次美妙的经历，我觉得我喜欢上学。当我不得不转学到初中时，我记得我们数学课的老师在学年初进行了一次测试，看看我们在数学课上知道什么。这是我第一次坐在排里，面向前方，而不是坐在桌子旁，我可以
talk to my classmates. So when I got to a problem, I wasn't sure about. I began to scoot my desk across the empty space between the aisles to talk to my friend who also went to the same elementary school. And the teacher was stupefied. Why would I do that on a test? And I was equally stupefied, why wouldn't I consult somebody else so that we could work on this together? Anyway, it's why I became a teacher. It's what I try to keep alive in my classroom today is that sense of wonder and how does what we're doing connect with the student's lives and their experiences. So I feel in some ways
和我的同学交谈。所以当我遇到一个我不确定的问题时，我开始把我的桌子挪过过道之间的空地，去和我的朋友交谈，他也上了同一所小学。老师惊呆了。我为什么要在考试中那样做？我也同样惊呆了，为什么我不咨询别人，这样我们就可以一起解决这个问题？无论如何，这就是我成为老师的原因。这就是我今天在课堂上努力保持的东西，那种好奇心，以及我们所做的事情如何与学生的生活和经历联系起来。所以我感觉在某种程度上
Molly is a textbook example of what it is that you're talking about here, Mary Helen. I agree with you, Shankar. I mean, I think, Molly, first of all, you're very lucky. And secondly, I think you've exactly nailed it with that example of scooching your desk over, where
莫莉是你在这里所谈论内容的教科书式的例子，玛丽·海伦。我同意你的观点，尚卡尔。我的意思是，我认为，莫莉，首先，你非常幸运。其次，我认为你用那个挪动桌子的例子完全说中了要点，在那里
your goal was to understand the math and be able to figure it out, or whatever was on your test. I forget what the test was about. Where the teacher's goal was to have you do that math in a very prescriptive way by yourself because that's what we have defined as the test of whether or not you know it. Both things have value in different ways, but we need to be much clearer about why we have decided so overprivileged, independent knowledge, working alone, working under time pressure, not consulting, not collaborating, and then we wonder
你的目标是理解数学并能够弄清楚它，或者测试中的任何内容。我忘了测试是关于什么的了。老师的目标是让你以一种非常规范的方式独自完成数学，因为这就是我们定义的测试你是否知道它的方式。两者在不同方面都有价值，但我们需要更清楚地说明为什么我们决定如此过度特权化独立知识、独自工作、在时间压力下工作、不咨询、不合作，然后我们想知道
why in the workplace later our young people don't know how to think in these ways. Mary Helen Imordino-Yang is a psychologist and neuroscientist at the University of Southern California. She is the author of Emotions, Learning and the Brain, exploring the educational implications of affective neuroscience. Mary Helen, thank you so much for joining me today on Hidden Brain. It was an immense pleasure. Thank you, Shankar. Hidden Brain is produced by Hidden Brain Media. Our audio production team includes Annie Murphy-Paul, Kristen Wong, Laura Querell,
为什么后来在工作场所，我们的年轻人不知道如何以这些方式思考。玛丽·海伦·伊莫迪诺-杨是南加州大学的心理学家和神经科学家。她是《情感、学习与大脑：探索情感神经科学的教育意义》一书的作者。玛丽·海伦，非常感谢你今天加入《隐藏的大脑》。这是一种巨大的荣幸。谢谢你，尚卡尔。《隐藏的大脑》由《隐藏的大脑》媒体制作。我们的音频制作团队包括安妮·墨菲-保罗、克里斯汀·王、劳拉·奎雷尔、
Ryan Katz, Autumn Barnes, Andrew Chadwick, and Nick Woodbury. Tara Boyle is our executive producer. I'm Hidden Brain's executive editor. If you enjoy today's conversation and find Hidden Brain to be useful or thought-provoking, please consider joining Hidden Brain Plus. It's our subscriber-only podcast feed, where we bring you ideas and conversations
瑞安·卡茨、奥特姆·巴恩斯、安德鲁·查德威克和尼克·伍德伯里。塔拉·博伊尔是我们的执行制片人。我是《隐藏的大脑》的执行编辑。如果你喜欢今天的对话，并发现《隐藏的大脑》有用或发人深省，请考虑加入《隐藏的大脑》Plus。这是我们仅限订阅者的播客源，我们在这里为你带来你在其他任何地方都听不到的想法和对话
you will not hear anywhere else. Plus, you'll be helping to provide the fuel for the research, writing, fact-checking, and sound design that is involved in every episode of the show. To subscribe, go to support.hiddenbrain.org. If you're using an Apple device, you can sign up at apple.com slash hiddenbrain. Again, those sites are support.hiddenbrain.org and apple.com slash hidden brain. This December, Hidden Brain is proud to join Pod's fight poverty.
此外，你将帮助为节目每一集中涉及的研究、写作、事实核查和声音设计提供燃料。要订阅，请访问 support.hiddenbrain.org。如果你使用的是苹果设备，你可以在 apple.com/hiddenbrain 注册。再次重申，这些网站是 support.hiddenbrain.org 和 apple.com/hiddenbrain。今年12月，《隐藏的大脑》很荣幸加入“播客抗击贫困”行动。
We're teaming up with other podcasts to raise funds to lift three villages in Rwanda out of extreme poverty. Your donation goes directly, no strings, no middleman, to the families who know best what they need. Visit give directly.org slash hidden brain to make a difference for someone who needs it most. That's give directly.org slash hidden brain. I'm Shankar Vedantam. See you soon. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们正在与其他播客合作筹集资金，帮助卢旺达的三个村庄摆脱极端贫困。你的捐款直接流向最了解自己需求的家庭，没有附加条件，没有中间商。访问 give directly.org/hiddenbrain，为最需要的人做出改变。那是 give directly.org/hiddenbrain。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。很快再见。本期节目还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。